foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh we missed it
the wheels the wheels have come out that
could be the match for some this is
familiar ground oh my goodness Knight d8
whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be Electric
ity the moves will be fast it's game
over it's winning oh my God he's gonna
make a queen the stakes will be high he
just grabs his head he can't believe it
he just gave away the pawn the 2022
speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome into another quarterfinals
matchup in the 2022 speed Chess
Championship International Master Danny
wrench alongside the Grand Master
naroditsky Donya how you feeling this
morning I'm feeling great good afternoon
everybody Carlson carlana up next Danny
I am beyond pumped I really don't have
any words to describe how I feel right
now I can't wait the world champion
playing in his second match of the 2022
SCC carwana coming off that super
impressive victory over irigaisy looking
even more impressive after irigaisi just
won the Tata steel blitz so man do we
have a good one in store let's remind
everybody down here before we jump in
what's at stake of course in the speech
has Championship you know it already
it's a hundred grand in total prices but
now that we're in the quarterfinals
Donya it's 4K base not 2K and 4K split
up based on win percentage of course the
winner will advance to the semi-finals
what would you do with four grand extra
in your pocket tomorrow Daniel besides
buy a little more caffeine and Lacroix
well I'd go to the the new steakhouse in
downtown Charlotte where the
cheapest item is ninety dollars then
maybe I'd put some money down for down
payment and uh I'd have a couple dollars
left over for a birthday gift for your
kids Danny well apparently four gonna
goes a long way in Charlotte down
payments and everything I love that all
right well uh we're gonna be we're gonna
be talking about what the players are
gonna do with their money throughout the
day as as we learn who's going to be
taking home the cash but let's remind
everybody who's already taken home that
cash to get into the quarterfinals on
the left side of our bracket we see both
Hikaru Nakamura and the hell Soren made
it into the semi-finals and they were
both pretty dominant janya of the two
players who do you think showed the best
for him punching their ticket through
well I have to point to nihal's Art I
mean for Hikaru Nakamura um literally it
would be a great upset for him to lose
to anybody other than Magnus Carlson so
he's expected to advance but nihal
started I mean he beats dang in the cgc
he runs him out of the gym and now he
runs him out of the gym again for God's
sake ding is the world championship
Challenger yeah
let's remind everybody he he also beat
both dingly Wren and Anish gear in
reverse order in the chess.com Global
Championship right so dingley Ren Anish
giri is supposed to be more household
names than Nihao Sauron but uh not so
fast the young man from India is saying
I've now beaten these guys twice in two
of chess.com's biggest events in 2022
and uh will he be someone who can give
hikar a run for his money or maybe uh be
the first person besides Magnus Carlson
ever to beat Hikaru Nakamura in the SEC
format so we will find out of course
when that matchup comes up this week but
right now it's time to talk today's
matchup Dania here we go we have the
world chess champion the Norwegian World
chess champion taking on Fabiano caruana
uh these will one of these two will be
the next player to get through to the
semifinals as we look at this matchup on
paper Dania I know we could talk a
million story lines but what is speaking
to you most right now about this matchup
well obviously there's the subtext that
this is a rematch from their world
championship match so both of them have
a chip on their shoulder particularly
Fabiana car one we're going to be
talking about that throughout but
Carlson has a major lead across all
formats so there's no question that
Magnus Carlson is the favorite in this
match Fabiana carwana is the underdog
and you don't say those words very often
so how is Fabi going to handle that role
today yeah and you mentioned of course
Magnus has been the better player pretty
much in all four months remind everybody
he has an 11 to 5 record in classical a
13-5 record in Blitz again I'm not
counting draws that just tells you that
Magnus has been the more dominant player
of course we know he's also a great
Blitz and bullet player uh Fabiano has
also never made it past the
quarterfinals in our SCC format will
today be the day that he shocks the
world but uh all right let's talk about
the format speaking of that the SEC
format is one that is a little different
than the World Chess Championship rapid
tiebreaker we keep referring to from
2018 a 16 player knockout of course is
we know the players are looking to score
points through different disciplines as
the time runs out if we get to a tie
break it will be four games of one
minute before ultimately Armageddon and
a fun bidding process Dania as we talk
about the time controls tell the world
where you think you're you're sitting in
the scripture right I just gave you the
script on you you're in Hollywood and
you're writing that upset story what
happens in these time control segments
for Fabiano to shock the world today
yeah I mean we've had a lot of comebacks
in the bullet segment in the SEC this
year which is pretty unusual I mean you
know sarin lost the three-point lead and
almost lost Dimitri on draken had a
three-point lead going into the bloke
but in this match Danny I really think
that Fabi has to strike in the time
control he feels most comfortable and
that is five plus one that is most
similar to classical chess Fabi has
professed his love for classical chess
many times so he's got to get off to a
good start he's got to make Magnus feel
unsettled he's got to make Magnus feel
like he's having another one of those
subpar performances right and that can
be tilting for anybody
but you know Magnus mentioned in the
interview that you and I had with him
after sending gukesh home that he wasn't
happy with how he played and
acknowledged he knows he need to play
he's going to need to play better as
this event goes on uh but you know
facing Fabiano he's got to be feeling
confident in all these time controls do
you think that do you think that an
early win by Fabiano maybe an early
several wins has the potential to Rattle
Magnus or do you think he'll find
himself no matter what as the day goes
on
I think Magnus has shown in a lot of his
long chess.com matches he's played in
the past few weeks that he is incredibly
hard to Rattle I mean Hikaru Magnus
they're kind of in the same category he
sort of plays the same way every game he
has the same style he grinds every
single game but he's also human uh
believe it or not I know that's a pretty
controversial statement breaking
breaking news breaking news so the more
you shorten the match the more you keep
it close the more nervous you're gonna
make him I mean you follow the classic
Sports advice get it to the fourth
quarter and stay within stay within 10
points okay and the SEC basically stay
within two points right all right well I
I don't even know that we've quite made
our predictions I think like many we
know Magnus is the favorite and the
corona probably has to strike early if
he has a chance and maybe surprise
people the increment in bullet is always
a little different which is why if it
comes down to that last time control
with a little bit of extra time on the
clock with that increment on every move
it's not just straight up bullet so if
it's close maybe fobby will have a
chance there but all right we've given
our our thoughts on how it might break
down what did smarter just say was going
to happen today we see a six to three
prediction in 5-1 two games up in the
three plus one segment and then another
six to four score for Magnus so he
pretty much has the world champion
dominating throughout Anya yeah
Fabby basically has to flip the
narrative in the five plus one segment
he's got to basically go something like
six three and create that two or three
point cushion going into the three three
plus one and this is no knock on Fabby I
think this is a fair prediction and uh
you know we're trying to find the
balance between building up the hype and
you don't really need to build up the
hype in a Carlson Carr want to match up
but also being realistic and
realistically this will be a huge upset
if if Fabby manages to pull it off it
will be well if he can strike early in
the the fans will be then on the edge of
their seat uh will will smarter chess is
80 victory for Magnus Carlson proved
true or will the communities prediction
prove a little more true let's let's
take a look at that because the
community
is even is even more uh in favor of
Magnus moving on with a 96 Victory you
know I think part of that is a lot of
people rightfully so maybe thought that
it might be irigaisy facing off against
Magnus again Bobby Bobby proved that
wrong with an epic match Victory there
over Arjun uh but only 406 people had
Bobby moving on to the semi-finals your
thoughts I mean geez what does the man
have to do first of all don't show this
to Fabi uh let's keep it away from him
you don't like it when he's angry you
won't like him when he's angry yeah oh I
do I mean what does the guy have to do
to make people believe in him right I
mean he just wins match after match and
you know still people just don't quite
confide in him but listen I get it
Magnus Carlson is the world champion
he's so stable and when he plays
terribly by his own admission he beats a
2700 with a score of 23-7 Danny so yeah
you know the stats kind of do speak in
his favor I get it yeah well you know I
think one of the things I'll predict
early in this matchup we talk about what
are we going to see on the board uh with
the players I think we'll see Fabi bring
bring something in terms of prep I don't
know what that looks like but I think he
will try uh to get some advantages early
on I don't think he's going to be
holding a lot back knowing that he needs
to score points especially in the time
controls where he has a little more time
on the clock whereas Magnus on the other
hand I wonder if he'll mix it up and
poke and prod or will we get 2018 World
Chess Championship rematches a bunch of
special cops we didn't see coming and uh
and a grind it out Affair your thoughts
on the X's and O's we might see on the
64 squares we're gonna definitely get an
opening duel in this match there's just
no question in my mind that Fabi has to
exploit all of his strengths every
single one of them his calculation his
ability to think and produce accurate
moves in critical moments and of course
his incredible vast opening preparation
with both colors I'm expecting one E4
from Fabi I think we're gonna get a good
amount of re Lopez's and I actually
think that both of these players are
going to be ready to change their
opening choices at the drop of a hat if
something doesn't work out just given
how versatile both of them are
I agree and I think I think that if one
player shows they've brought more in
terms of prep than the other they are so
versatile they're not going to be
hesitating I think to switch it up
quickly getting a disadvantage out of
the opening against caruana if your
Magnus or vice versa is not something
that they want to they want to have
happen and uh speaking of things we want
to have happen lots of hair memes coming
our way apparently Magnus brought that
extra Volume Shampoo this morning to
really get the really get the energy
going you wonder you wonder if he blow
dries his hair at all for these uh what
do you think hey we asked him in the
last interview but he was in a fantastic
mood Danny as you remember he was really
in a talkative you know he was in kind
of a chill frame of mind he played three
against cash so he really expanded upon
his shampoo routine didn't he yeah well
uh the routine the routine these guys
know well is now underway we are into
the games here in our next quarterfinal
matchups of the 2022 speed Chess
Championship thanks for being with us
everybody and uh the day is underway
Magnus Carlson a classical
let's go Carlson carwana can't believe
we're watching this Magnus has the white
pieces here and this 94 variation which
has been around since since the Medieval
Times of Gary Kasparov in the 90s
it's an interesting it's an interesting
approach the White Queen is often okay
on C2 you're going to develop naturally
with E3 and Bishop D3 the pawn already
guards before but Fabi playing quickly
here so he's clearly got some sort of
prep he's about to show given how
quickly he committed to this line like I
hate Magnus I wasn't surprised by your
classical nimso
yeah and taking the first think of the
game developing the Knight to C6 which
should also be pointed out in this line
you often try to push C5 but recently
players have actually been pushing on
the king side G7 G5 and then H7 H5 is
actually not out of the question even if
you've castled King said because that
Bishop experiences a lot of problems and
if white has to play H3 in response to
that Danny that after Knight takes G3
White's entire kingside structure is
ruined and the e-pawn is weak so I think
Fabi or is thinking between Bishop F5
and a team move like rookiee which he's
just played but that's not such a tame
move after all he's setting up Knight
takes D4 threats wow Knight takes D4 if
Pawn takes we move this Knight discover
check Bob's your uncle on E1 and drops
The Rook man I love highlighting as you
speak can we keep this relationship more
often I feel like I learn more for the
at you know coming from the school for
kids who don't just good who don't chest
good you air you Arrow good though so I
graduated the school of the school where
kids don't chest good to Arrow good
um all right well The Rook is on Eighth
there are immediate threats with Knight
takes D4 uh jokes aside and I love your
point about G5 and H5 it's such an
instructive thing to see that normally
blocking a c Pawn in a queen's Pawn game
which is any any real Central structure
where the queen pawns are the ones that
are the furthest most advanced everyone
is is a queen's Pawn game and normally
you want the C Pawn open but in this
case getting your getting yourself in a
spot to focus on the king side
this is some Dynamic stuff and Magnus is
already down 20 seconds on the clock
yeah this is an incredibly dynamic
position with a ton of options on every
move we see Magnus going for the more
pedestrian Knight F3 yeah white can also
Castle Queen side here that's not out of
the question either although of course
the queen side is not exactly the safest
place to be but with black unable to
open up the C file easily that really
builds the case for white going Queen
side rather than King side and now where
is Fabi gonna deploy his Bishop F5 or G4
or is he gonna Resort back to G7 G5
H5 come on Fabby if G4 I expect Knight
E5 will be played to prevent Knight
takes D4 tactics but note everybody if
the Knight went anywhere else you might
be right back there so instead
[Music]
this is I mean I'm gonna be honest okay
this is earliest game one but if I'm if
I'm honest about how I would have been
in Bobby's Corner massaging his
shoulders chest boxing style I would say
look Bro you've got to go after him like
we're not here to mess around right
you've got to go after Magnus and get
points early and often in these slower
time controls so I love what I'm seeing
here and from personal experience
playing Magnus and long Blitz matches I
think his one tiny Achilles seal I mean
yes who am I to talk about magnus's
Achilles seal I can understand the irony
of that but he is a bit of a slow
starter it sometimes takes him a couple
of games to get warmed up and listen we
saw this against kukesh it was 1-1
gukesh had many chances in the first
five six games I think Fabi noticed that
and he says hey this is where I'm going
to try to strike every game is important
every opportunity has to be exploited
and Magnus kind of struggling to find a
move here he simply ignores the threat
of H4 wow wow is that a bishop that can
be trapped are you just happy to see me
Donya H4 Bishop E5 F6 there's Bishop
takes C4 E4 yeah it's a classic idea
actually and then Queen takes E4 with a
check on G6
speaking of slow starter can we just
call out that Magnus
Magnus looks like he needs a banana
remember last show where we had uh we
had bananas at the ready Magnus is
looking like you need some potassium a
little vitamin B maybe a little caffeine
he is uh looking a little exhausted
there
um let's bring up the analysis board if
we can real quick just to show some of
these uh some of these variations
because we are in a sharp position here
if F6 occurs Bishop takes E4 take shake
and bake mom helped right takes E5 and
we get checked white has at least a draw
but maybe even more right Knight takes
G5 yeah White's got the draw in in his
pocket with Queen H6 check but Knight G5
is possible you could also go Queen H6
check and then Knight takes G5 so you
could really massage this in many
different ways and Fabi wants to avoid a
scenario like this if he can so F6 is
not forced here Danny you could consider
Knight take C5 you could consider Bishop
F5 but the thing is you've already
committed to all of these Bond moves and
then suddenly reverting back to a normal
developing move I actually think that
might be the way to go preventing Bishop
takes E4 okay horns can't go back thanks
Captain Obvious but it is it is
important when they push in front of
your key your king to remind ourselves
of those basic rules and we by the way
have H4 and Bishop E5 on the board so
you your suggest question of Bishop F5
looking more and more prophetic coming
from the prophet called it there we go
yeah he just didn't want that scenario
where Magnus has at least a Perpetual
pretty terrifying and now F6 is a
massive threat so H3 uh might be what
the doctor ordered for Magnus
yeah F6 traps the bishop so you've got
to do something spicy now
before before that Bishop gets in
trouble he has two and a half minutes he
is up 30 even 40 seconds right now on
carwana so talk about a game that gave
us a little bit of an opening struggle
Donnie these guys spent a lot of time
navigating whatever this Theory or prep
was and only 15 moves have been played
and we're about to be under time
pressure and here comes C5 I think
trying to drive that pawn down to C4 and
exploit the awkwardness of that
relationship between the bishop and the
queen but Fabi taking more of a slow
roll approach and and yes we're gonna
get a lot of time scrambles in this
match just because of the incredibly
complex style of both players they are
such principled players they're going to
get complex positions every game and I
think a big determining factor is going
to be who can keep their wits about them
in Middle game time scrambles yeah
well now Magnus is uh still in that
lounging position
I see Chad saying he's bumped he's
missing the uh semi-final of uh one of
the World Cup games hey Chad please
don't tell me the score I'm recording it
yeah no no uh World Cup spoilers for
Donya I don't really care you can you
know you can whisper to me although my
whispers are blocked on Twitch for good
reason so frankly do whatever you want
to do chat
um shout out to feature chat though
we'll be checking in with you throughout
the day so Jokes Aside give us give us
your comments see you see your comment
right on air and ultimately comments
will be read to the winner of this match
at the end so uh
so play along with us Chad all right
castles Rook C8 Here Comes C5 for black
as you said I'm expecting it
um oh Bishop G6 first we'll see that'd
be delay delaying C5 waiting for the
perfect moment to strike maybe bishop G6
can come to H5 at some point to harass
indirectly the pawn on E5 uh also
putting the bishop on a defended square
is a good idea now Knight D2 threats are
eliminated I I like Fabius position I
think he's doing fine here but once he
plays C5 things are kind of gonna
explode yeah it's funny because now that
the bishop is protected you're right
you're not worried about pins this
Knight can't really move without this
Pawn hanging in a lot of positions so
let me ask you does Bobby have to play
C5 like what's what's to just kind of
sitting in this position what is White's
plan I guess to ask the question
directly oh yeah not an easy position
but Knight to H2 what what if by Carlson
now his idea is obvious you're pointing
it out but it looks like it hangs the E5
Pawn which Fabby grabs but F3 and Bishop
takes G6 Danny that Queen is gonna
appear on G6 and guess what Bobby's
moved B7 B6 yeah he's going to pay for
it that pawn on season can be captured
wow he missed it look at his his yeah he
missed that pawn he he uh
a bit Magnus spotted that what a
what an idea what an idea what foresight
to see the weakness of B6 when we have a
second let's head over to the Batcave
and bring the analysis board back I want
to just show the the Killer Instinct
from the great white shark that is
Magnus Carlson look at this position we
talked about maybe white doesn't have a
clear plan but B6 creates just a subtle
problem at the end of the line and note
that Bobby has to take E5 because
otherwise the Knight comes to G4 you
take E4 and the pony pops so this
combination that Magnus spotted is just
incredible I mean Knight H2 is such a
seven head move and things kind of
getting crazy in the end game it looks
still looks dangerous for white with
that Knight sitting on G3 Danny there
are some mating ideas for black but but
Magnus has left himself plenty of time
to navigate the complexity here I think
he's gonna take this game he could play
E4 here he could give a check on E5 I'm
gonna let him do the calculation but
back to your point Knight H2 and F3 what
a concept by Magnus yeah and again like
it was a good concept regardless of with
opponent E5 but it only really works
because the C6 Pawn is hanging at the
end and we saw favi's reaction in real
time what a combo Magnus Carlson not the
worst chess player I've ever seen
only the second worst we'll leave the
second worst um all right Rook d8 played
Bobby's not gonna give this one up and
the time scramble will be will be
commencing it shall's commence
umst but it's only a one-sided times
girl and I think Magnus could send his
F1 up as well at 43 a 5d2 I mean it's
still a three result game
uh but White's pawns should decide with
accurate play finally Magnus sits up
yeah well he's gonna get under oh not
yet oh
yeah
oh my gosh here we go get your running
shoes on the pawns are pushing who gets
there faster
this is F6 check King D6 and white loses
the E6 spawn I think Magnus might have
overlooked that
crazy Danny by the way he woke up thank
You Velvet Canyon for waking up give us
your comments we love feature chat King
D6 Rook C1 yes by 93 okay he finds it
982 check and then the king escapes the
pin so that's not possible Fabi brings
his King up
oh Rook D7 oh that's a knife that's a
knife right there
take D2
he's gonna pick up the pawns and it's
falling apart for Fabi totally winning
now
this is blunderable man this is blender
100 night takes F5 tries to capture no
but just take an E7 yeah this is over
here comes the queen yeah oh man you got
problems here you got problems here
unreal what a what a game one
what a match we are in store for you
know when that King D6 line was played
with Rook C1 Donya I thought for a
second maybe black should have sacked
the Knight on F5 Knight takes King takes
E6 forcing 93. I don't know if there was
anything there with Rook D1 and then the
other one comes to C1 but
anyway sorry
yeah no one full chess player never go
full chess player on a chest show did
you catch that for Magnus what did you
just is there like a a b that he's
trying to ward off what was that hand
motion right there
it could be like a fly in the room it
could also be just negative thoughts
he's saying get thee behind me you know
I only won in 40 moves I wanted to win
in 20 moves but listen the eval bark did
come down briefly but I wouldn't put too
much stock in that Magnus was in control
of that game really for the entirety uh
of the latter middle game and end game
it was virtually indefensible
practically speaking yep all right well
as predicted we have yet another battle
of theory if uh you're one of the more
advanced players in chat you might want
to get your get your notebooks out these
guys are going to be playing prep today
these games are going to be in databases
somewhere this is now some Mainline
Spanish stuff the players are stopping
to think uh deep respect they have for
each other thanks Yoda
um and much much
preparation they have brought
yeah this of course was uh thoroughly
explored in the Magnus nepo match I mean
Fabi has written a book on the real
Lopez with white so I would consider him
the leading specialist yeah on on the
Roy Lopez as it stands right now and an
interesting Pawn structure
transformation as Magnus strikes with D5
and the idea of this move is to
establish a stronghold for the Black
Knight on e4 or to get an iqp structure
where black has control of the square in
front of it which is the most important
thing yep
love that highlight there that
transition is really important for
players to note I'm just going to
quickly show that because if you're if
you're ever going to make this big trade
you're helping white get squares for
pieces so you have to follow it with the
transition of D5 to try to go for the
iqp otherwise you've given white this
Square you've actually temporarily even
given white the two pawns so really
important just kind of positional nugget
to put in your pocket take home you can
use it later
um the currency is is better than better
than crypto these days oh did I go there
um the knowledge nugget um anyway ev5
Knight D5 and we have an iqp as
predicted this is what black has to do
if you're opening up all of these all of
these minor pieces for white
yeah this is this is a really
interesting middle game now of course
black has kind of an equivalent weakness
on C7 but that is not an easy weakness
to access Black's light squared Bishop
big question here where is it gonna go
is it gonna go to E6 to support the
Knight or is it gonna go to B7 to aim at
the white king I I like Bishop B7 yeah
but it's a little bit Yeah gotta watch
A6 if you go to the king side right
um
this is a funny transition for white
right Dania because it's not the bishop
has moved so many times in this Lopez if
you go back we're already looking at
four or five moves for just one piece
but the bishop recognizes it's maybe
maybe not ideal here not just because
it's being poked but maybe there's a new
Target if the pawn ever pushes B5
becomes available so the bishop on this
diagonal at some point is also useful
ooh wait
Magnus is threatening the B1 Knight so
no taking the pawn just yet
no taking the pawn just yet but it's
it's on very thin ice that pawn is under
arrest I don't know if it lives in a
penthouse in the Bahamas though but it
ain't feeling very good right now
okay the Knight will be able to develop
to C3 now the bishop of course guarding
this Square excuse me ooh Black's pieces
looks so nice so good look at those
minor pieces
man look at that look at that yeah yeah
yes sorry remind me of the minor pieces
I had against it's a little early for us
to go Lone Pine sorry go ahead
well how to get to the light squares
um actually but seriously black is
dominating the light squares let's Let
It Be noted
um I feel like the Eva bar hasn't woken
up yet yeah the evil Bar says Danny and
Dania are freaking out over little
things but this is high level chess we
are exchanging a six for D4 a for d
um
black will win this Pawn everyone
probably that's what we're gonna see
yeah I was gonna say I don't know that
white has any other option
so Knight takes D4 again Magnus looks
unhappy so you literally cannot judge
the position based on his body language
I think the reason he's concerned has to
do with that past Apon which can
actually jump to A5 and if white can
successfully maintain his control over
the center and prevent tactics related
to Bishop takes F2 check and keep that
Knight on C3 under control then white
does have this major asset on the queen
side so it's actually quite a bit more
double edged than I initially thought
also it's one of those long-term assets
right I mean no matter what happens in
the center this is an outside pass Pawn
you can bring home to Mom and Dad you
know it's a long-term advantage and it's
not going anywhere of course if the Deep
Pond Falls black also has a c Pawn but
not quite as dangerous as the napon
okay so Knight takes D4 has been played
big question what is Magnus gonna
recapture I mean he's probably going to
take on D4 I thought about 95 here
briefly intending to meet Knight C2 with
90 Knight C6 but that was way too
specular if he takes with the queen so
he wants to put a rook on d8 and just
press on White's minor pieces yep this
bishop of course is stuck to guard the
Knight
so this is this is a little irritating
right of course the queen a little bit
tender in the center there's all kinds
of moves you just start looking at to
gain a Tempo but not right away Queen
takes A1 would win the exchange that's
an important little tactic so yeah Fabi
needs a very composed move here
something like Rook A2 or Rook C1 what
are those cagey moves that just does I
just better say Rook C1 then you can
meet Rook data with I think Bishop E3
you get out of Dodge and suddenly you're
you're okay but at the end of these
lines we have to remember when there may
be weird exchanges the bishop takes the
Knight and the Knight wins A4 so keep
that keep that in your Road in your road
map at the end of some of these combos
but Fabi taking his time down to 90
seconds now on the clock and the
complexity showing no signs of abating
he moves his Queen away
intending Rook a to D1 in response to
Rook d8 Danny but uh Bishop C2 Bishop C2
chases the rookout he might have missed
that detail that is a nasty move oh
thank you good yeah I just got sour
lemon face it was like
call
what is he what do you do then if you
can't let's bring up the analysis board
and take a quick look oh because Rook d8
is played if the move Rook to D1 is on
the board we're gonna see the move
Bishop to C2 and it is yeah agrees this
is oh it's not on the board just yet I
think I noticed it and the problem and
now it is he's played Rook 801
ah Bishop C2 maybe Rook C1
and he's holding on for dear life it
barely works it barely works and it was
funny it barely works but in the end you
will have the past eight Pawn we've been
talking about so it just it's
okay we're getting action we'll stay
with the live position here wait A4 just
Falls straight up didn't even see that
coming duh because he played Rook a to
D1 so to meet Bishop C2 with Bishop E3
but that drops the a pawn and now Fabi
firmly on the defensive he's lost his
main asset
yep Magnus is unfortunately
bringing the bringing the heat early we
we made a call that one of the few
Achilles heels for Magnus in these SCC
matches has been a slow start he started
slow against gukesh as well uh you
called it Dania maybe he maybe he heard
it through the subconscious ether devs
of the of the universe
I think he's made a conscious adjustment
to you know I wouldn't say take the
first couple of games more seriously he
takes them plenty seriously but you know
he consciously realizes how important it
is to set a good tone and can Fabby hold
the draw here this is an early big game
Danny I mean he goes down 2-0 that's a
very unpleasant hole to find yourself in
when you've just woken up in the morning
and you're already down 2-0 well
especially because you know the
storyline you know what people are
probably saying has to happen for you to
have a chance in this match if you're
the American it's hey father you gotta
win in the Slow Time control so if you
start down two games in the five minute
portion knowing you're not really
looking forward to Bullet uh that's when
that's when tilt can happen right that's
when a match can get away from you the
good news for fobby is that his pieces
are well placed and the C7 bond is very
much immobilized like it can go up to C5
you have to watch for tactics Bishop
takes D5 and Bishop takes F7 but even if
you avoid that how do you get the bishop
off of C4 White's got a ton of activity
here to compensate for the loss of the
pawn
Fabby should hold this with with careful
play
but it's Blitz for a reason right should
and Will are two very different things
especially when it comes to fast time
control games
so by the way don't blunder Bishop G6
everyone white will just take your
Bishop that's a pinned pulling on F7
um and on it is maybe bishop E6 but then
white takes
and then you gotta take back with a pawn
okay that's awkward that's awesome
that's awkward that's as awkward as our
commentary I was about to say the same
thing
chat was having a field day with that
that was what Chad was thinking of
course awkward awkward AF awkward as
fobby as we like to say
um
[Laughter]
but anyways okay where is he gonna put
that yeah this Magnus hasn't made up his
mind because they were sitting here
laughing Magnus took more than a minute
on that move over about 57.4 seconds to
be exact as we look at the time logs on
chess.com uh oh Rook takes E3 easy to
miss so easy to miss yeah okay just
everyone visualizing your head takes
take shake and bake on E3 black wins The
Rook so Bobby had to see that which he
did magnets down to 10 seconds I mean
okay
Bishop G5 you can't take C7 because of
the check on E1 I think you have to
trade the Bishops and then maneuver your
queen from H5 to G4 and try to
infiltrate C8 and he's doing a perfect
job you were threatening it so Magnus
defended it I highlighted it as you said
it Queen d8 there is no Rook D1 check we
got double protection on this Square so
okay so Bobby please G3
just sit tight if you're happy but don't
allow The Rook trade Queen E2 yeah maybe
move your king to H2 but but whatever
you do don't allow Rook D1 check
for those watching Donya speaking
Grandmaster knowledge there a rook
ending is much easier to hold than a
queen ending with an outside pass Pawn
here so if you had to if you had to make
a trade you want to trade the Queens
here not the Rooks
three seconds for Magnus he's making
moves with one second left he's trying
to get a rook to the second Rank and he
just did
but I don't see it
66 Rook D1 what a trap
here
look at me oh my gosh he's making
progress he's just gonna push it oh you
loud Rook D1 H1 C E3 is over here that's
it
Magnus bye
Magnus doing what he does
better than anybody in the world which
is convert on these small advantages you
know I was having a combo with Robert
Hess in the car
um on the way back from the airport
yesterday in fact Robert is in town
he'll be hosting tomorrow's SEC with
Donya from this chair
um and we were ranking Hikaru and Magnus
skills done and we were talking about
hikaru's uh skills of Defending and
persevering in those resourcefully kind
of bad positions you put it 99 out of
100 and then we said Magnus at
converting small advantages is probably
99.99 out of 100 right he does it better
than anybody in history and right there
it doesn't matter that it was maybe
equal he just finds a way to convert
those positions it's so tough to hold
and that's why any time you have these
long-term advantages he's up a pawn in a
middle game you're kind of screwed
because you can defend perfectly for 30
moves which Fabi did he's gonna get you
down on the clock and then he's gonna
find some arrangement of pieces to trick
you every single time he does it in
classical chess and he's adapted himself
perfectly to Blitz I mean he's carried
over that skill from classical to Blitz
which is just so impressive to me yeah
all right well back to another
theoretical battle note that uh
are you okay
sorry about that I I muted myself but
you did we heard every minute you heard
that cuff I'm falling we heard that
cough it was a bad coffee swallow
there's I know the expression in Russian
you say
um I swallowed down the wrong throat
there we go yeah yeah there we go
um
anyway note that Magnus put the
classical to the classical nimso which
means I think he liked he liked Bobby's
position there if you're just tuning in
game one was an interesting classical
nimzo where Favi went for it with black
and frankly had a very good position
before time pressure
um and and then Magnus kind of squeezed
one out but
um but here Magnus avoids the mainline
nimzo instead we are in a Catalan
um
it's just always interesting to note who
varied first right we bait we had a
nimso starting and Magnus said I don't
want another classical Nims though so
just always make a little notes about
how they're shuffling
yeah this is such such a a popular line
popular structure and I to be completely
honest with you Danny I'm a little bit
skeptical of fabi's opening Choice here
because in this line you're basically
playing for two results I mean black has
a lot of activity on the queen side but
Magnus just loves these positions where
he's up upon and he can squeeze a small
Advantage for 30 40 moves so Fabi better
be super accurate here with his king
queen side activity or we're gonna get a
repeat of the last game yep
oh little advantages converted by
magnets what a move
sorry dude go ahead no if takes takes
the G2 Bishop Falls
how did Queen takes B4
and there's a a rook hanging on okay
analysis board please no no Bishop takes
u5 immediately Queen takes before Oh
Queen takes B4 immediately okay
for kids who don't chest good but
highlight good let me show you takes
takes
there's a few kids in the chat who don't
chess as good as others um but they do
love learning visually
I'm your man I'm your man you're welcome
Chad
um and note that if you take your first
White can even take here with Tempo and
then you got problems so actually turns
out Daniel was right Bishop G5 checks
out we get take take black keeps the
bishop here but no white still up a pawn
and if we get a single Knight versus
Bishop minor piece Dynamic that's a
winnable end game for white on one side
of the board it most certainly is and
and Bobby playing this so well he's he's
just taking it to Magnus Queen E4 and E5
he had to find those moves now the queen
on b4s or the pawn on D4 is pin Rook D1
takes takes rook d8 and I think he's
winning the pawn back and the moment he
does you can basically agree to a drop
maybe F3 should be tried here by Magnus
but that's a risky move then you're
playing for three results
yep but maybe it should be tried
oh F3
kick that Queen out free up my ability
to trade on E5 as you said you
definitely don't want black to take on
D4 even if you're not winning the pawn
that isolates the pawn and probably
black picks it up later so so the
Queen's gonna move that's gonna unpin
the pawn which means white is going to
take on E5 I'm imagining
obviously a queen trade would be ideal
here for Whitey I was gonna say the
other move was creepy one but okay he
does it now I like that Queen B1
yeah one difference
one difference we got to know from the
last game is it's a small Advantage
again for Magnus he does it better than
anyone but Bobby up a minute on the
clock almost and that's a big it's a big
change Bobby has sped up
you sped up he has plenty of time to
defend this but I would totally ignore
the Evo bar here this is exactly the
kind of physician Magnus excels in like
I said yep he's up a pawn and there's
the compensation is pretty clear White's
King is weak the second rank is weak
Abby's going to deploy his Rook to B8 or
see it on the next move or maybe even d8
but you know Magnus can can torture this
out for for an indefinite period of time
and he's going to try to push his Pawns
in the right way and you know get the
Queens off the board but but Fabi should
totally hold this
and we talked about that I'll just add a
little more context the reason why we
said the Knight versus Bishop Dynamic is
is more winnable than let's say Bishop
versus Bishop is the Knight thrives when
everything is on one side of the board
it gets to switch colors okay thanks
Captain Obvious but it's super important
the Knight can poke and prod and then go
to a different color and so the knights
in time pressure especially thrive in
these in these games so this is not
nearly as easy as the email bar is
saying it is and if you had a bishop
versus Bishop I'd be calling this game
as a draw and he's just using time but
Knight versus Bishop white is
legitimately playing for a win here
and H5 from from Fabius he tries to drum
up some concrete play against Dwight's
King he wants that pawn on H3 to create
the long-term precedent of of mate
threats I I love them of H5 and big
question for Magnus does he push E5 and
then play Queen E4 or will he bite off
more than he can chew no I think he does
there's also even okay he goes Queen E4
right away I thought of queen of five
induced G6 then you come back and
there's more threats of E6 okay he goes
Queen E4 right away
okay Fabi occupies the open file
sensible move
sensible Sensible yes
93 you could try to activate the knights
Annie but then the rook in full trades
D2 and then you start you start sweating
because then you know it becomes a three
result game once again I was gonna say
the one thing going for uh black here is
exactly what you said this second rank
is not something
that you can turn your back on
yep
yeah he's thinking and he's down more
than a minute on the clock so fobby
holding his own
sticking in it
well given that he's up to zero the pro
I think Magnus is going to err on the
side of caution yep or not or not as he
pushes F5 he just feels Invincible right
now I was distracted by the chat comment
that said if I had magnus's hair I'd be
unbeatable I agree I agree sorry so yeah
no he's not sitting tight he has F6
coming E6 coming by the way Queen E2 now
okay he's gonna check and then go to F3
with Tempe
if the King goes to H7 I thought he
might try to go at F6 on the next move
but then actually Fabi can take twice on
F6 notice the Knight on G2 oh he's
blocking the king's Luft Square yep take
take Bishop take shake and bake Rook
takes you've got Rook to D1 game over so
you got to be careful I think you'll
play Queen of three agreed and then
Bobby should take on E5 I was gonna say
does he just exchange e for H and
actually that's a that's a favorable
exchange for black for sure a hundred
percent because then even if the Queens
are off the board God forbid that is a
lot more drawable for black so Queen F3
is kind of an admission that yeah my
winning chances are super limited but
otherwise again white might risk losing
maybe E6 can be considered here yeah
and if you're the defender in these
positions everyone you want to trade
pawns and the more you trade pawns
equally assuming nothing else bad
happens along with those exchanges in
theory you're getting closer and closer
to an end game you can hold so so okay
E6 as you said what's what's the main
point obviously
you don't want to take
but what do I not supposed to do I guess
you have to I think you have to take and
I was thinking maybe white wants some
Queen E8 Queen takes H5 Shenanigans but
again the threat of the back ring check
uh persists even if the Queens are off
the board so I just think Magnus is
going to recapture and try to use the E6
Pawn as a decoy and go after that H5
Fawn and black is starting to suddenly
experience problems for the first time
in this middle game with his own King
yeah
because of this idea also the f file
feels super dangerous okay now fobby's
all in this is kind of instructive in
that he's playing active defense he
knows he can't just sit tight he's got
to create counter play he's played
active defense for the entire the
duration of this defensive task and it's
been great H4 another good move he's
just trying to get all the pawns off the
board and H3 is very tempting but the
Knight jumps into F4 and suddenly things
get dicey there you could lose that H3
Pawn note how key the queen is
defensively guarding both H5 and F5 yeah
massive
this is still very difficult for black
but Magnus down below 20 seconds
I'll be correctly managing his time here
we always talk about the difference
between taking your time and managing
your time he had an edge on the clock
that was a big decision and look the
email bar agrees with him he made the
right one with HG not H3 and he uh he
took a few seconds to make sure
he made the the appropriate and critical
pollen decision and he's whittled the
pawn count down to a two versus one
obviously if he wins E6 it's just an
insta drag actually then the bishop
might be stronger than the Knight so
maybe it's time for Queen F5 check which
is not quite a draw for white could
still squeeze the for a couple moves
there but Bobby's gonna hold that and
Magnum behind the pawn you get King here
in Bishop F6 this should be holdable now
well rookie four Knight F4 Bishop D6
might be just a force draw because you
lose E6 I think yeah straightforward
Bishop D6 Bobby finds it yeah that's
gonna make the exchange we have a draw
Magnus is gonna play it out now as far
as the meta strategy goes because of the
match format with the time ticking down
and because Magnus believes he's the
better player with faster time controls
everyone don't be surprised if you see a
lot of games like that where they don't
just extend you know right no draw offer
here Anya let's play this thing out to
just Kings and I think that's important
you know I think remembering that the
clock Dynamic is is equatable to ball
control right in the NFL or or you know
the shot clock in the NBA if you have a
lead milking a little bit of that clock
some patience is part of what makes the
SCC format unique and um anyway so don't
be surprised if you see Magnus play a
lot of games out
and some people get annoyed when games
are extended we saw that in hikaru's
match yesterday he was literally you
know sitting out the rest of his time uh
when it was made in one so you could
look at that negatively or you could
choose to look at it positively and say
hey this is an interesting added wrinkle
the gamesmanship the match strategy is
kind of interesting to me to see how the
players think about it it's just an
added element of complexity which is why
we love matches because it's not just
about the chess games it's also as you
said about the meta strategy and
speaking of meta strategy Bobby already
switching to 1d4 and we've got a super
complicated nimso Indian structure here
yeah the uh
zamish variation right he plays A3 this
is a very direct forcing way to just
your opponent develops into nimzo and
you say all right I'm gonna make you
give me of the give me up give me up the
bishop give me up there Bishop give me
up that Bishop man tell you what okay I
don't know from South Carolina
I don't know I don't know what we're
doing right now but the Knight comes to
H3 to deal with the threat of Queen H4
but this is again this is Theory right
these guys are not shying away from from
prep and you'll note that I think
comparable to other matches where you're
getting you know b3s on move ones or or
just anything to make it uh kind of a
unique a unique game with no prep this
is the opposite kind of kind of match
we're gonna have today yeah we called it
I mean they're playing principal chess
every game whether it's E4 or D4 they're
going for all of the Hot Stuff
um you know Donna Summers pretty happy
about that but okay this this kind of
structure has gotten super popular again
after years of dormancy like people
weren't playing the same-ish for a while
and suddenly they're playing it again
and I think it's because computers have
breathed new life into White's King side
play in these positions black has this
very classic idea Danny B6 yep Bishop A6
Knight A5 and you go after the C4 Pawn
but White's got a lot of action on the
king side you could play G4 you can push
E4 I'm always skeptical about White's
position here because I feel like there
are a lot of weaknesses but for a
dynamic player like Fabi it you know
fits him like a glove yep you
highlighted it it well and again the
forced variations of the zaimish which
are defined by the move 5a3 were not as
popular because this positional Edge
seemed like something that that will
inevitably favor Black in the long term
and as Donya just said he kind of likes
likes black too there's also Rook C8 to
come so really you could just say the
doubled c-pones are doomed that's not
the question the question is what you
see on the board right now what will
white get in exchange change for the
positional catastrophe of a queen side
with the bishop pair on the king side so
note that Magnus is going to do
everything he can to keep the game
closed not let the Bishops Break Free on
the king side and hopes to long-term uh
focus on these positional weaknesses I
love these types of games because it's
so easy to observe what the battle
revolves around you know White's trying
to open up the king side get something
going there in Black just keeping
everything closed and it's a matter of
time before Magnus goes B6 and Bishop A6
and starts to wind his tentacles around
that very weak Queen Side Pawn mask so
the ball is very much in fobby's chord
and here we go E5
and this is what the computers have
changed yeah this is this is what the
computers have changed Don you mentioned
that just to highlight it the computers
have shown us that this position just
look at the eval bar currently white has
double Pawns
an awkward structure and is down a pawn
but the computers understand that
there's a lot of dynamic potential here
there's there's moves you even can take
this forget what the email Bar says if
you get Queen E2 Rook D1 you've got
ideas here and yes Black is Black is
going to be positionally winning but the
computers have shown these positions are
a lot a lot trickier than we than we
think
yeah and chess history as a whole not to
get too and deep into the tangent but it
can be divided into these eras where
sometimes positional thinking dominates
and sometimes it's the opposite and
right now with the Advent of alpha zero
and Leela and all these engines that are
super Dynamic it's a tactical era like
we you know all these tactical lines are
super popular again nepo's playing the
king's Gambit you know the zamish
variation uh you know we're getting a
lot of Sicilians again and it's it's a
super interesting time to follow high
level chess because you know players are
back to back to a romantic style but a
2022 romantic style of course
agree totally no it's it's funny the
computers in the early 2000s were were
uh were marching marching down the
street you know we were announcing the
death of the game and Fisher random was
not just the question of whether we like
it it was a matter of when the game you
could argue was more Dynamic now than it
was 20 years ago uh because of what
we've seen and I love A4 it just shows
that this position is like Poland's only
a mother could love ugly ducklings but
you can't take it without the dark
swears getting loose it's just it's just
weird AF it's weird as Bobby Aaron
capablanca would have a heart I mean he
would just look at look at this position
and say where has the world gone we are
we are degenerates yes uh if this is
what chess looks like in 2022 Irish
pawns on the queen side Black's got
double pawns
for both sides now you can't take C5
because of Bishop A3 so believe it or
not the queen side pawns are actually
quite safe I like White's position me
too the eval bar disagrees no I like my
position too
are not only saved tactically but
they're also potentially an advantage
because by definition when you have
double pawns you have an open file
because they came from somewhere right
and so you see that white will have
potential here despite the Eva bar
giving a slight Edge that's that's a
that's an evil engine slight Edge pay
attention to the human tactics here
especially in Blitz and note that Magnus
clearly taking time which is not
something he does unless he knows he
needs to figure things out so
um I love what you said about the
positional chess error right Zurich
International 1953 by David bronstein
you'll see some incredible nimso Indian
games back when this Amish was super
popular or white for the other reasons
before it became like Oh Black is
positionally out playing you so um check
out that book If you're looking for some
really interesting ways to improve your
positional understanding great
recommendation it was one of my prized
positions so much so that I had this
book cover for my grandparents and you
know I I put that book cover on that
book I mean it's just such look at this
penetrating annotations and here we go
Knight D6 followed by B6 undermining the
Knight but as you're pointing out here
comes the bishop but then BC but you can
go first and then take and then Bishop
A3 and Bishop a G6 also don't forget
about that strike dear gosh these are
the Bishops that make Aaron nimsovich
and again capablanca wrong you know with
their positional bias like it's just
it's about to just get freaky here right
you're gonna take the bishop comes this
bishop comes white is white is winning
the exchange here the question will be
will Fabi want to take it because okay
unless black has 97 which
I would I would rather give up The Rook
okay here goes Magnus he's something
just open it up and his idea
specifically is Bishop takes E4 Knight
takes E4 and if Bishop takes f8 he might
have a check on G check on G3 and he's
hanging by a thread but if you're Fabi
you might just want to take the Knight
on e4 and make the Practical call and
then play something like C5 to undouble
your pawns Rook fe1 I mean lots of items
on the menu here for white let's bring
up the analysis board when we get a
second because I want to show donya's
Knight G3 check I think you were not
only right Dania I think that that was
incredibly critical for Fabi to see that
idea that was like I wanted to tell you
to shush your mouth when you're talking
to me because look at Donya shushing his
mouth look at this potential trap Magnus
just laid and suddenly boom I was
calculating that in my head as you said
it and I was like it's not just it's not
just the practical decision Magnus being
Magnus had set up a really freaky forky
looking trap that freaky forky looking
guy you know look at that I love I love
the way Magnus is handling the defensive
task and just like Fabi defended
actively in the previous game here
Magnus is doing the same thing he says
hey I'm losing all my pawns I get it let
me create some counter play against
Dwight's King here comes the other Rook
to D2 this is terrifying for Fabi even
if he's winning objectively because all
of Black's pieces are in the attack
Knight to D3 is a smothered mate threat
oh my gosh I was like I didn't have a
response so I there's also Queen coming
out here and and at some point Knight
cakes have three threats right because
you're getting oh my gosh you're getting
shellacked over here on the second rank
this is
this is wild Bobby sees 93 wants to put
the bishop on D4 I don't not like it
well Knight Z3 there's also this weird
move Rook b a kind of forcing the
Tactical Queen trade but even in the end
game your Pawn on G2 is under serious
fire
so oh oh apparently Knight D3 wasn't the
move I think you have to go Rook V8 now
um
you could play
where can you go you can play Queen C7
and actually that might be the Fearless
way to continue but hey I don't want to
have anything to do with that line I
mean if I'm either color
Queen to C7 not only guards the bishop
who by the way guards Checkmate it keeps
the threat of Rook to B8 alive and by
the way so you got a second ring I've
got a seventh rank Dania I I preachy7 if
he's okay he doesn't he goes that I
think you were right I think Queen C7
was probably the best engine move G2
will fault now oh it's gonna fall but if
you're what Knight H3 Knight H3 might be
an even better way to do it I think
Knight H3 white will play Rook to E7 but
then you can just take the Rook after
Knight H3 black might be in the driver's
seat look at that move Knight H oh he
misses it Knight H3 if takes it was mate
oh and if you took and the King took it
was mate by the way Knight H3 was
freaking crazy for Magnus he's gone
Knight D3 he's gone the other way where
is he going I think Knight E1 and Knight
takes F3 maybe he also wants to push the
E Pawn and obviously dislodge the Bishop
from this diagonal it's anybody's game
Let's watch Magnus switches to the a
pawn he's now a little worried time time
ticking away for both players
he's down three pawns and I think it's
gonna be a draw talk about some bad
pawns coming back to bite you in an
inside look at this the uh the storyline
of the nimzo proves correct you have
three extra pawns and they suck sorry
can I say that they suck no they suck
and he's not even taking them quickly
he's taking them at his leisure yeah
this is hilarious
she's going back to C2 and saying you
can't move
okay it's gonna be a draw
Bobby not gonna convert this one
and as I said I I think you're going to
see Magnus play a lot of games out
Bobby's just sitting tight saying look
man
this is over
but uh
okay there's no way to lose this King
and pawn ending
yeah I mean you got to be a little
careful but with Magnus you can lose any
end game that's that's fair that's fair
two games that basically end in Bear
Kings I love it yeah and again as as we
said I think that Magnus wants faster
time controls I think right now he wants
a break we see him scooting back his
chair he's aware that we've reached the
halfway point in the five plus one
segment he is protecting a two-game lead
that scoreboard will be updated in just
a second it is currently three to one in
favor of the world champion after that
after that draw uh and uh and we're
gonna take a break let's show everybody
where we sit in terms of the score as we
as we get set to head uh into uh into
the back half of the five plus one
segment we um we see Magnus again even
in that game where he was in trouble
Dania holding on and and making it
making it difficult for Favi to convert
the dub
yeah it almost seems to me in the early
going that that Magnus is controlling
all of these games even when he's worse
and yeah that's a very alarming feeling
that that like one of the players is
always in the driver's seat despite the
objective evaluation and that is what
it's felt like it just seems like Fabi
is just a little bit less sharp just a
little bit less acute in these time
pressure situations and it's only a
two-point deficit the last two games
have been encouraging for Fabiano I mean
they could have gone either way and he
just has to keep making it complex and
keep trying to outwit Carlson in these
super principled openings I agree and I
think even if Magnus has been in control
I don't think Fabi has come with a with
a passive mindset he was playing really
aggressively with black in game one that
game was was this close to going the
other way but as we said the credit goes
to the world champion for even when he
has that sense like Hikaru does the game
is slipping and he made it spicy to make
it really hard for his opponent to
convert and that's what that's what the
best ones do they don't just uh lay over
and take it right they make it really
tricky and that's why they're hard to
beat so all right we're going to be hard
to beat today I got a feeling this
commentary Duo I don't know what's going
to happen with our relationship by the
end of the day but I'm open to it I'm
dangerously open about where our
relationship is going we're gonna we're
gonna take a quick break for the SEC
don't go anywhere Dania and I will be
right back
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we are back now
for the quarterfinal matchup in the 2022
speed Chess Championship taking a look
at Fabiano caruano currently down three
to one in his match versus the world
champion Magnus Carlson by the way
sporting that botez swag shout out to
the boat test sisters and their new
merch line did you know that Donya they
sended you a hoodie to wear they sent me
two hoodies and a board and I I texted
Andrea I literally did not wear anything
else for two weeks and I still it I have
a lot of sweatshirts so there's a lot of
competition it's entered my regular
rotation fantastic quality so
comfortable yep that bow Test sister is
expanding in the merch we saw there some
quick uh some quick
stats on the American Fabio caruana
Precision indeed I would say is his
skill set it's hard when you're going
against Magnus Carlson who is very
similar to Fabiano in a lot of ways
maybe just a little bit better and
sometimes that's harder to play Someone
than who is stylistically very different
Magnus and Fabi very similar in Styles
Magnus just has has an edge in a lot of
those areas and that's why this matchup
tends to go the world champions way well
people love to ask what separates
Carlson from the rest of the super GMS
and we see here that there is no easy
answer it's a combination of very small
things taken together a little better in
time pressure a little better in the
opening a little better in tactics a
little better at calculations all those
minor things but taken together they
produce an absolute monster okay next
game underway and we have yet another
opening a Petrov yeah I said by Mr
caruano okay you were saying the
advantages taken together by Magnus
separate him it's the little things when
these two guys get together we see this
opening a lot or at least we did in the
2018
World Chess Championship a few times the
Petrov of course a pet line for Fabiano
caruana an opening he is very much one
of the world's leading experts in
yeah and we're going down one of the
main lines
white usually plays C4 in these types of
positions although recently we've seen a
lot of players going for Knight C3 or
Knight bd2 and basically playing it
without C4
yeah and Magnus taking his time not
because he doesn't know the line but he
respects fabi's prep in this position as
black and wants to make sure he
remembers all his theory before he
blitzes it out commits to the Knight bd2
variation
uh
again this position has been played many
times just opening book it up take a
look at it
yeah and and the other reason you take
your time in the Petrov is because it's
it's like you know the the road system
in Atlanta you have freeway interchanges
with seven different directions and they
all look very similar yeah and in the
Petrov you've got like three or four
different lines where the pawns are on
D4 and D5 but all of them are a little
bit different and you're supposed to
play all of them differently so even the
top players get confused the Italian is
exactly the same way and I like the way
Carlson is arranging his minor pieces in
the early going here
agreed and this is an interesting
maneuver of the night to come to F1 and
E3 to gain a temple before white
convinced a castling is is one of those
many complicated intertwining freeways
that look similar but is actually very
different the Knight on E3 prepares to
play C4 in some more aggressive Fashions
often because it's hitting hitting the
D5 Pawn so that Queen to B3 can come and
you're building pressure exposing the
absence of this light squared bishop and
again sounds obvious but the Knight
actually doesn't have another Square
where it can put pressure on D5 because
if it goes to C3 you'll get exchanges so
so this maneuver is it seems subtle
everyone but the footwork the footwork
is very high high level with these two
heavyweights and Carlson taking his time
now deciding between C4 which he's just
played the other candidate move was
Knight F3 to E5 aiming for the bishop
pair but again Carlson taking the more
ambitious route which has been a theme
thus far in the match just never shying
away from positional risk and and
complications Danny I love it yep
willing to isolate the queen upon
willing to iqp it up note of course
Bobby took right away because we didn't
want to see the lines I was talking
about with Queen B3 white has a little
bit of an edge here
why does an edge because his pieces are
much more active another way in which
our understanding of the game has
changed modern computers often give
white an edge despite the fact that he's
got an iqp and black controls the square
in front of a deep Fritz would probably
say that this is slightly better for
black but stockfish 15 always
prioritizes peace activity and tactical
potential over a static Factor because
the D4 Pawn is not really a weakness
it's actually very well defended by the
Knight on F3
love that throwback to the Deep Fritz
reference deep Fritz was one of the
first computers to win a match versus a
top human of course everyone remembers
deep blue versus Gary Kasparov in the
90s but uh Fritz Fritz started playing
matches and beating the world's best
humans but even so the eval of a deep
Fritz computer the approach of a defense
computer wouldn't even wouldn't even
hold a glass of water against against
stockfish today they're just they're not
even in the same universe
they're not they're not they're not and
and look at Carlson just deploying his
pieces one after the other the queen
comes out to its traditional B3 Square
you're doing two things aiming at B7 and
now Knight C to E5 is very tempting to
attack F7 but I think Fabi has prepared
Queen D5 which is really a buzz skill
kind of a move and a queen trade plays
of course right into Black Sands look at
Knight A5 [ __ ] the night similarly in
that it opens up the queen but it hits
B7 and note the distraction if the queen
defends it guess who else comes to E5 I
got two phones Mr F3 Knight that's right
we got two knights are better than one
this is this is just some uh some good
good old-fashioned family fun here right
PG rated so stick with us all day 95
Knight ft5 there's even Bishop F4 there
the thing is if whites play evaporates
again statically positionally black is
better so Fabi is just a couple moves
away from solving his tactical problems
yeah and Carlson has to has to try read
very carefully as well let's not pretend
that this is a one-sided position Magnus
might be having the fun right now but
give it five moves and the tables might
turn I love how you highlighted that
because it's kind of like the dimso
reverse structure we were at least
storyline from what we were saying last
game yes white has the dynamic pressure
now like Fabi did with the Bishops in
the last game but there's a reason deep
Frisk used to favor Black because this
is a weakness it's not going anywhere
and so if I can just just beat back the
Lions I'm gonna be better if I'm Fabiano
and he is beating back the enemies at
the door I think if he plays Knight F to
D5 or even Rook a to d8 Carlson Was
preparing Bishop F4 with his last move
wait what oh you couldn't take with the
Knight cause would be a pinned the
Knight that was a discovered attack very
nice pretty
okay so Knight B to D5 gets away with it
there was no B7 Pawn they played him
very quickly
note the speed from Mr caruana
yeah no this is great he's playing
confidently he's playing in he's playing
very carefully he's incorporating these
two three move tactics into his play
like the last move Knight B to D5 seeing
that B7 cannot be captured by either
piece and he's doing great with the pawn
I think he's gonna take with the pawn oh
he doesn't I like it because Mufasa
oh yeah bringing back an old throwback I
I didn't forget that
it was it was last week Donya I know you
host a million shows a week but you know
it's like an eternity ago
I think fabi's better I I love Bobby's
position I said Mufasa not Magnus for
that reason G takes F6 was was nice but
seriously one double Pawn for another
but this one holds the E5 Square ensures
that white will be in a defensive spot
with the d-pawn and
this is this is looking better and
better for car one yeah but how do you
make progress if we take the Dell's
Advocate approach here the pawn on D4
still very well protected and you need
to find a way to involve your Bishop the
ideal score for the bishop is F6 but
tonight okay sir yeah or that but but
either both squares are basically
inaccessible so carwan actually changes
the structure and says I don't care
about the Deep on give me the D file for
my Rooks
I like it give me Iguodala baby look at
that he exchanges exchanges the d-pawn
for activity not something you you know
again nimsovich would be rolling over in
his grave he would have played this
thing uh tried to milk the positional
Edge forever but this is the dynamic
approach again we see from Modern
players the Rooks had the f file the
Rooks have the second rank this diagonal
also opened so notice the engine like
black the engine's like black because a
very very timely opening of the position
for carwana and the pieces are better
and you're not going to beat Carlson
every time in a position like this but
carwana keeps giving himself chances
he's now had three of these positions in
a row and the first two games ended in a
draw can he pull one out here with
Carlson also quite low on on the clock
and can Fabi just keep the tension long
enough to get Carlson under 30 seconds
up on the clock
another pretty good position for Fabi he
has yet to get a victory in this match
if you're just tuning in that three to
one score came via two draws and two
victories for the world champion so
Bobby needs to strike and get a dub to
show he can do it
but I like the way Magnus is defending
just kind of making these short range
moves and keeping all the bases covered
he could play Queen E4 here and offer a
queen trade
I don't know I don't know if Abby's
creating enough chances here I not know
why not no
sorry
okay not no
uh
no that was misplaced that's not where
you're supposed to you're supposed to
say it after like an impressive move you
know or after we show a pretty line
yeah all right takes on e4 black is
gonna be a teensy-weensy better because
just like we said the Knight is better
when pawns are on one side of the board
the bishop is better when there's
weaknesses on either side if you could
just put a rook on the second rank you'd
have great chances if you're fobby but
Magnus is saying not in my house thank
you to cambi Matumbo not from my house
and the unspoken the unsung hero of the
of the defensive effort has been the
Knight on F3 it's defended the D4 Pawn
like a champ and now it's defending the
D2 square and it hasn't moved the entire
time it's been stationary and it's an
amazing piece
Here Comes Rook D3 if the Rooks are
traded the black Rook will have some
opportunities to swing to the queen side
you've got Rook B3 Rook B4 you know
you're trying to inchwarm your way so
Magnus isn't going to let that happen
relying on that Knight flexing his
muscles Garden D2 but Rook D1 Fabby
continuing to poke and prod trying to
get his Rook to the second Rank and he's
gonna maybe go Rook to B1 and Ty White's
Rook down to B3 the plenty of juice to
be squeezed in this position rookie I
would go Rook B1 right now I was gonna
say yeah that seems like an awkward move
I'd love rugby one now you can't stop
Rook B2 because the beep one hang so
obviously I'm not one to criticize
magnus's moves very often I'm wondering
why he chose B3 but clearly the evil Bar
says nah he's doing it right and that B3
Pawn is problematic if he plays Rook C2
then five people go Rook D3 and tie him
down further so Carlson trying to find a
different spot for his Knight maybe get
it around to F4 but Rook D2 is now
possible and he's played it yep
this is what I was nervous about the
Rook will hit on B2 at some point really
keeping everybody stuck and then the
only question is is there a way to make
progress this Knight was a stallion on
F3 seeing the feature Chad more of a
donkey now on H3 not where he wants to
be he's going to take but here goes
carwana getting a bit of an advantage
and he's gonna have some made threats
after Rook B2 Bishop G1 has to be kept
into account although Knight F3 yeah
defends pretty nicely the problem is
that with every Pawn trade white strong
chances grow maybe it's time for King F6
you know I was just gonna say where does
that night go F3 and The Rook has D3 in
the event of Bishop B4 so Carlson
holding the fort for now look at this he
says he doesn't believe in fortresses
and then he goes and sets up one that
darn Dirty Dog Magnus this looks like a
pretty good Fortress to me
keep protein and prodding if your car
want a rookie two maybe rookie three a
rook trade is not out of the question
given the disparity in King placement
but more Pawn trades on the horizon is
he gonna play F4 F4 says five he's
playing for a win no he's taken there
this is going to be a draw now he ain't
he ain't getting past D5 with his King I
mean that Rook on D3 is is such an
annoying piece
yeah yeah set up this is now easy
the setup is uh is picture perfect with
the The Rook guarding the Knight The
Rook guarding the pond the Knight now
guarding the pawn like everything is
just being held perfectly on the light
squares
the uh the bishop feeling more and more
empty with its inability to Target
anything
and um
okay usual time pressure am I about to
have one of those okay no he's offering
a drug with this I think but I was gonna
say it was Magnus about to flip the
script here and try to play for a play
for a win we saw this yesterday with
Hikaru and you're not it's not an absurd
question to ask the answer is actually
usually yes yeah
um and if if the match is tied then
Carlson would be you know playing
another two minutes and a little head
shake there from Fabi he's getting kind
of progressively more frustrated a lot
of chances here nothing concrete he was
never totally winning he wasn't winning
in the last game but you know with every
one of these missed opportunities Danny
you get more frustrated because how many
times are you going to get good
positions like this against Carlson
exactly and you can lose a match uh not
just by losing games but by missing your
opportunities to win right because at a
certain point it catches up with you
against the against another fellow best
player in the world you can't always be
better in a middle game or out of the
opening so you got to convert on those
opportunities and it's it's hard when
Magnus just seems to always get off the
hook you know
and it almost seems like he he's not
even close to losing I mentioned this in
the last game it's not just that he
defends but it's almost as though you
know he's worse conceptually but if you
actually look at the Arc of the game it
doesn't seem like he's concerned at all
it doesn't seem like he's anywhere near
losing these games no matter what what
he has on the clock
yeah it's crazy we take it for granted
how accurate of a Defender he is but
he's revolutionized that just the art of
Defending slightly worse positions look
at him grabbing a pillow there to keep
his arms comfy everyone loves a good
everyone loves a good wooby
and a sip of he's scared I like to keep
my Beth Harmon wig close just in case I
ever get lonely wow
that's so cute
okay I'll put it over here
adorable making me melt
all right another isolated Queen Pawn
potentially on the board here when the
tension between the D4 and C5 pawns
break staring contests right now uh and
ultimately fobby blinks first as I will
trade in order to try to get the bishop
here move the Knight and play against
the iqp but nope Magnus Magnus loving
himself some iqp structures against
Bobby today
yeah he's going for them with both
colors and I've analyzed these
structures pretty uh pretty extensively
and and black again another example of a
position which in 1960 would would have
been evaluated as a clear Advantage for
white I mean Knight C3 to E2 to D4 you
know that's the textbook approach but
Black's got a lot of juice on the Queens
on the actually both sides of the board
you can get the Bishops off the board
and then try to put a knight on B4 I
mean it's equal objectively I think
maybe only a tiny Advantage for white
yeah
and again we see Magnus willing to play
these positions especially now that he's
got that two-game lead he's not going to
Blink as far as playing positions that
are you know just about equal and and I
can hold I think that every game that
that goes by we get closer to faster
time controls where Magnus I think feels
that his Advantage should only grow
we'll see if Bobby can surprise the
world and and change that storyline
remember he was losing to irigaisi and
ultimately completed a comeback there
Fabiano and so you know I don't think
he's uh
he's he's saying that he has no chance
in the faster portions I mean Fabi
played amazingly in the bullet segment
so I I really can't wait for the bullet
um and I he definitely doesn't mind a
you know one or two point match going
into the bullet so Carlson is trying to
strike a balance between playing solid
chess he doesn't mind a couple draws
here and there yeah but at some point
he's going to want to try to make a push
to extend this lead to four or five
points going into the bullet we said
this was going to be an epic and epic
match of course whenever these two guys
get together you got to remember 2018.
but the chest the chest I know it's a
little different than maybe wild
scrambles we've seen other games this
has been maybe the most high level SCC
chess as far as prep goes we've seen in
any match like this is this is some high
level neither player wanting to budge or
take too many risks in these in these
very very closely contested positional
games the quality of play has been
fantastic something another thing that
we shouldn't take for granted the lack
of blunders the lack of swings of the
evaluation bar in all the these games
had stayed amazingly stable even in time
scrambles I mean both players really
putting everything out on the table and
Carlson has definitely improved his
level of play as compared to the gukesh
match just considering the objective
quality of his moves here but Fabi again
with with an edge in the end game I mean
this is not fun for black we'll see if
he can push on both sides of the board
he's had Magnus up against the ropes a
few times these boxing references that I
normally make in my commentary now feel
even more kind of appropriate given what
happened this weekend highest highest
ever viewed stream on Ludwig's channel
one of the highest ever on YouTube if
you missed the chess boxing Affair where
were you
um but yeah he's got him on the ropes
will he deliver a blow is the question
right it's hard because Magnus knows how
to defend
well I think the ref might have to step
in and declare it too much because then
you change the result of a match
black looks kind of woozy you know he's
kind of stumbling around I think it's
time to end the match
uh
all right well this is uh
this is gonna be a
oh he plays E4 he's gonna say this is
gonna be a long drawn out kind of um
King E5 King E3 uh-huh and then there's
F4 check coming but this move smells
then D takes C4 and then Knight D5 check
I don't get it at all King E5 King E3 we
can pull up an announcement but I mean
he probably is gonna play these moves
yeah in short order
I think that's what he missed
if we look at the analysis I think it
was King E5 King E3 takes takes Knight
D5 yeah the engine agrees with that line
and that's no wait Magnus takes right
away and then King E5 at the risk of
putting this bishop on a nice diagonal
but even so I don't think Fabi
took the right approach there just
checking on the body language of the
player is doing what Bobby says not to
do read too much into their read too
much into their facial expressions
um
I mean I'm also puzzled by the move
order in in the way that Magnus is
playing us but I get it because now if
the Knight moves away from D4 there is
still Knight D5 and guess what White's
King is just too far away from the
action you could end up losing your
queen side pawns and Fabi cannot afford
to lose this game I mean this will be a
crying shame if he loses a game in which
I mean he was playing with zero risk
just a millisecond to go yep
it's it's very un unfabi-istic to play a
move I think like E4 here instead of
keeping to keeping the grind trying to
re-maneuver and poke and prod I'm not
saying he's gonna win but this was a
this move E4
going for the forcing lines where black
has some obvious Tempo moves to grab
control over the center with his King
mm-hmm that's that's probably the match
score and the desire he feels to get a
dub catching up with him and it's and
it's an over estimation of the role that
the B7 Pawn is playing I think that's
what really attracted Fabi to this move
he thought oh Knight B3 Knight C5 hey
I'm going after the C Pawn but he
underestimated the role of King activity
in this position and the power of the
move Knight to D5 B4 is just as weak if
not weaker than B7
was just highlighting that the B4 Pawn
is a problem and if you if you go for
variations where you have to take well
now this King you can get Knight C5 all
defend the all defend upon and who's
going to win over here active Kings will
uh will
will be the deciding factor in otherwise
equal end games
also Bishop takes G4 is kind of in the
mix in certain positions so I didn't
even see that
that was funny kicking in huh at last
and actually you could play it now
and get an extra Pawn
it might be the best move the ship H5
yeah I mean I'm not gonna lie I'm a
little disappointed it took you so long
to spot that tactic
in that position
if I'm disappointed too there is B5
I'm gonna try to remember
all right
we got to redirect the analysis about
okay Magnus doesn't go for it but we
gotta show what might have happened had
he taken
take Bishop H5 is there weirdness here
obviously if you take A6 is good you're
losing your knight
um yep I thought so but if you take with
the Knight then takes here
anyway so baby black could have done
this but he doesn't and again I think
the match score influences Carlson's
decisions in that resulting position if
lag was risking a little bit that was
not that was getting a little dicey with
that with that past a pawn even if black
was better objectively so Carlson trying
to manage the risk here and this should
still be a draw Knight takes before
Bishop takes B7 maybe bishop B5 and
black is is massaging a nice Advantage
here all of a sudden yeah you hold the
A6 Pawn the truth is A5 becomes the
weakest peshka on the board the Knight
Will re-maneuver itself eventually to
Target the pawn after Bishop B5
um yeah yeah you repeat the bishop on D7
too yeah it's true
there is some you know some weird
ways to kind of
poke it poke at this King side if you're
if you're fobby
yeah definitely
okay Magnus thinking he used his time
Advantage well we say managing your
clock
versus uh taking your time he's making
sure he makes the right decision might
ultimately just be deciding how
aggressive can I really be here I don't
want to lose maybe he decides to
simplify
whoa that is a big move Bishop C6 and
Fabi saying no I want the Bishops on the
board which makes sense because he's
anchored himself to the A6 Pawn
Bishop B5 maybe he's reticent because of
Knight to F5 you mentioned attacking the
king side can't fall asleep on that
Carlson continuing to sort of
re-maneuver his pieces around but he
might be overdoing it I think he
overcooked it a little bit and I think
the worst is behind Fabi after Knight F5
and Knight D4 yeah know that the king
had some landmine squares he would have
loved to consider getting more active
and running but every time Forks your
uncle over here on F5 and you pick up
the G7 Pawn so Magnus ran into some
struggles there clearly didn't quite
know how to handle it Fabi like you said
probably seen the worst of it will he
switch back to playing for a win you
know I want some mutual time scramble
you said the email bar hasn't been going
up and down I showed up for the eval bar
to go crazy and Spike my blood pressure
this is my exercise so let's get it
going look at that F4 and G5 another
excellent defensive idea by Fabi HD hd5
93 to G4 check knocking the king back
then F takes G5 and then White's gonna
have the outside passer with H6 so all
of a sudden again it's Carlson who's
just got to play with an abundance of
caution here just to make sure that that
you're actually throwing this game nine
F5 Knight F5 King d8 Knight G7 takes
takes H6 oh my God for F5
wait a second he's gone a different
route I mean the pawn
that idea was interesting right he's
gonna win the H Pawn oh Bishop F5 maybe
to keep the pieces alive
yeah black might even play Bishop E4
then to oh no Bobby Bobby's getting what
he wants which isn't all that race whoa
whoa whoa Knight G4 H6 and Knight F6 I
mean Black's King is gonna stop the pawn
from f8 but the king can be knocked back
with a knight check on D7
super dicey all of a sudden
H6 King f8 Knight F6 from Fabi threatens
Knight D7 kinda but then the king can go
to G8 yeah maybe it's a fortress Bishop
H7 is an interesting attempt there to
prepare 97. he moves back okay it's a
draw it should be a draw it should be a
draw White
had just a little bit of an opportunity
there but again if Bobby misses this one
he'll be shaking his head as we head to
the next game get ready for it because
Fabi looking for a way to get his Knight
around now he's worse again and imagine
might promote his pawn bishop D5 what a
move now if we know Magnus back in the
driver's seat make a move Magnus we
gotta move one second one second God oh
my God oh my God oh my God
Magnus is winning he's gonna go Knight
C3 and knock the bishop away oh my God
Bobby played F5 in panic he had nothing
else to do and it's over oh my God and
the mistake Danny the mistake for Fabi
was to get his Pawn to H7 because that
pawn immediately became a liability this
is unbelievable just let's bring it
let's bring up the analysis board real
quick and just show how that finished
that is that is what that is what Magnus
Carlson does right that type of thing
right there and we just quickly bring up
that board oop wrong board actually that
was impressive too by the way that was
the first time he did something like
this yeah we're back to the live game
but that that board there was absolutely
that finish there with the pawn going to
H7 was absolutely crazy
yeah the idea to show that during the
break I mean I mean ridiculous how he
I've got it up here if we got an
analysis board I can I can quickly just
show the Finish
well while they play this next opening
just to show that it was H7 the over
commitment of the pawn no apparently
apparently the games aren't in order
right now trying to get them up we'll
forget about it and and do it later
right now we'll go back to the live game
that is in progress but uh okay it's
never over with Magnus that's the lesson
from all of this it's like you you
literally can never relax he will find
chances based on a single pass Pawn
that's somewhere on A7 and before you
know it it's right in your grill and
it's making promoting to a queen yeah
ridiculous yeah yeah
um
I I'm shocked but also not shocked
Magnus and Hikaru are the two guys who
you know you see those things flip
around
that's why the game is played
time pressure puts the uh
puts the people in uncomfortable spots
yeah it's it's unbelievable and and it's
such a treat to watch this unfold and
right now this is a critical critical
phase of the match Danny for carwana
think about it there's 18 minutes left
okay that's probably two more games yeah
he really needs to try to go at least
one and a half half at least keep this
manageable because you lose another game
and at that point it's kind of
officially starting to look like a bit
of a blowout yeah well it starts to look
like smarter just will be right and no
one likes that right he predicted a
three-game victory not the exact score
necessarily that we'll have but he did
predict a three-game
a three-game margin for Carlson out of
the 5-1 portion
[Music]
um
okay
this is this is a you know a Petrov
yeah that's about everything we can say
about this position there's nothing
really else to talk about here it's just
a pet shop this is a Petra thank you I I
wonder if it's a picture of Danny do you
think this is a Petrov yeah
is it a picture of I wasn't sure what
you thought on a controversial topic one
of your solicit your advice on which is
whether it's a better off this is a
natural
okay well Carlson with a little pull I
mean the night the night is
n't better than the bishop here yeah
smidge
just a smidge
um but it's it's one of those positions
where again unfortunately for Favi the
small Advantage games have been going
Carlos Carlson's way today
um but nothing super exciting it is it
is a Petrov you know um which means the
structure is completely symmetrical
um
yeah you could also get this from a
Berlin by the way we keep saying Pet
Shop you could get okay maybe not the
exact piece pieces are a little bit
different but you could get something
like this from a Berlin yeah and this is
already starting to look unpleasant
um and and it's magnified no pun
intended when you're playing Magnus
every slightly unpleasant position
basically looks like a lost position
like you you you
underestimate your position and
overestimate magnus's position and
obviously that produces more mistakes
objectively this is very close to equal
but that Knight on F5 is nasty maybe
Queen F3 to x-ray blacks Queen and you
know typical Magnus stuff starts
happening yep
and at this point when you have an edge
on the clock too you're willing for this
one to go all the way down to the wire
not not gonna not gonna say all right
you've earned it buddy here's a draw
that's not that's not what they do here
um
all right well Magnus using his 30
second Edge to think about how to
approach because Bobby I mean Donya like
you can play C3 in Korea three you could
also go all in here a little bit right
at some point get a little here he goes
a little bit I was going to point out H5
and the idea is isn't quite tactical I
think it's more positional he's just
trying to create a lot of strain on
Black's King side right and maybe create
the preconditions for some sort of a
sacrifice on G6 which could not be such
a remote possibility Danny if you think
about it if the queen moves away from F6
it's already uh basically a reality and
the other unpleasant thing of course is
that white control is the only open file
which is always very important yep
here's my obligatory open files or like
Commodities reference supply and demand
if there's only one it's even more
important than an open board and yeah so
what do you do if you're carbona um
maybe bishop G7 and King f8 try to use
the goalkeeper
you know to kick the corner kick I don't
know
I like that put the King on f8 to get
the Rook to E8
but then Queen E3 white beats him to the
punch
it's annoying this is this is such this
is so vintage Carl Carlson carwana this
is like exactly like classic position
out of their game just a classic the
difference is when they drew 12 games in
the classical World Chess Championship
of course of 2018 as the time control
got faster the same type of style
ultimately really favored for Carlson
being just a little bit better in fobby
than Fabi in a couple of these areas and
and as the seconds take away so tough
and
um
we still got a long match to be played
we know that Bobby impressed everybody
with his bullet performance versus our
Junior geisi so by no means is it over
but stylistically this has been
carwana's problem against Carlson
throughout their career right that that
they're very similar both highly
accurate highly precise just so good uh
both very well prepared Carlson just
like carwana but a little bit better in
a lot of those spots
yeah that's exactly right I think that's
that that's the best way to appreciate
uh the nature of Carlson's three-point
lead none of the games have been
blowouts or we move wins or yeah I wanna
blunder to Fork here he's just squeezing
and squeezing and it's merciless he does
it every game and he's doing it again
here look at how he manages to weaken
the F5 Square Danny at the cost of a
pawn yes but it's not a very good Pawn
now he's gonna go Knight F5 maybe rookie
five and and it's just Relentless
pressure no matter how simple the
position looks he's gonna make it tough
on you yep
and it is super instructive I mean even
if it's not the flashiest sexiest attack
you've ever seen you know showing your
ability to to drive things like H5 and
eventually pry weaknesses and and make
make things happen in an otherwise
symmetrical three versus three pulling
structure I think a lot of lower rated
players look at those things and those
positions and they yawn or they check
out but while while engines have taught
us you know a lot of things about
Dynamic chess and how to persevere
there's always tactical shots they've
also showed us ways to this Alpha zero H
Pawn as we say they've showed us ways to
create chances when when otherwise
players of a previous generation maybe
wouldn't have fought so hard in an equal
position like this and that that is a
great point and it's a point that was uh
made also by vessel and tapolov when I
interviewed him uh a while back I was
actually commentating with them uh
during during the world's cup and he
mentioned that Magnus Carlson one of the
specific ways in which you revolutionize
the game is that literally positions
where players would have agreed to draw
10 years ago 15 years ago now they don't
even think about agreeing to a draw it's
it's not even a question that yeah
you're going to squeeze this for another
50 moves and uh it's amazing to see how
our understanding of the game has
revolutionized even compared to the
modern era and Carlson holds all the
keys to the kingdom here the king
infiltrating F6
I mean the king's coming in it's like
this is this is so hard to hold I feel
so bad and I'm down two minutes if I'm
Fabiano in addition to feeling like a
boa constrictor is wrapped around my
neck right it's like yeah when you wrap
your kids up to go out in the snow and
you wrap the scarf super tight and the
jacket and the gloves and just send them
out and they can't move yep like that's
what we're dealing with here like Bobby
was all dressed up and ready to go play
in the snow but he can't move yeah I
totally know what that feels like Danny
coming from San Francisco a lot of snow
in the Bay Area yeah you know I mean
it's it's uh
it's not fun and then you're sweating
the ton right you're warm even though
it's freezing outside you're dehydrated
I mean sorry
that's how Fabiano feels right now a lot
like that
no that's a good comparison and King F6
is still in play you could try to get
the King around to E5 and attack D5
another iqp position by the way this
time Carlson is on the other side of it
but I I don't think this game is over I
mean white still needs to find a way to
actually win material here win the D5
funnel or the H7 Pawn so a lot of things
that Carlson could try here
look at that principle of two weaknesses
eat your heart out right Magnus is
playing both sides of the board a very
very mature approach this is with time
pressure almost an impossible position
to hold I'm not trying to like like
check out here but like with time
pressure with Magnus with the weaknesses
on both sides of the board F4 such a
strong move to open up the chances of
creating other targets and I want to
point out especially to the young
players who are watching this match and
trying to emulate the greats how Carlson
is managing his time he's playing fast
yeah but he's not playing instantly he's
not trying to flag him he's taking three
four seconds of move and look at what
he's doing he's won the D4 upon and the
game is over
yeah and note that when you create
opportunities for your opponent sorry
when you create problems for your
opponent like F4 did again speaking to
the young players don't underestimate
the Practical power of that because it
wasn't just that F4 were threatened to
concrete with Rook H2 it created a ton
of problems a ton of things for Fabiano
to think about with no time and what
happened then black gets too aggressive
in their defense ultimately just loses
the Deep one straight up and so it's
just such it is a master class literally
to watch the patients and and again the
principle of two weaknesses is a
principle referenced in many many books
for a reason not just because it opens
up problems logistically X's and O's but
practically your opponents often crumble
in those moments we all love our tall
games our sure-off games our morphe
games but this is its own form of art
this is Art and and it's it's art that
only exists in the last 10 years only
Magnus can do this and literally nobody
can come close to squeezing out these
positions with the level of regularity
that Carlson does it not even Hikaru I
mean it's it's absolutely maybe in Blitz
but he does this in classical as well
let's not forget that he's emulating his
exact style in classical chess and he's
taking it to the splits match and look
at Fabi he says I need to win this last
game playing The Shining Hara Gambit of
getting a dynamic position I like it
I love it I want some more of it I need
this I need this aggressive play Danny
wrench the the game he played is black
with the G5 expansion in the classical
nimzo the game he played in the zamish
you got I mean he's got a little bit of
an edge here again we know Magnus has
gotten off the hook a few times but
still this is this is the game that
carwana has to go for Donya to beat
Magnus it can't be I just believe it it
can't be the small Advantage Petrov
symmetrical structure iqp stuff and it's
not because Bobby isn't better than
maybe every other human on the planet at
those positions but guess who the one
human is he's not better at in those
positions
is it uh Danny wrench it no it's the guy
I'm trying to point to you but I'm a
little dyslexic thanks weather man
Carlson up in the corner I'm gonna try
to
try to go up into his corner I'm gonna
go up in the magnus's corner of the
frame oh
I threw up my back
you're getting old man
anyway you get you feel me though right
it's it's hard because that's one of the
reasons why this matchup if your father
you got to be feeling frustrated like a
lot of people in magnus's generation I.E
the Jordan players in the 90s like you
know Magnus is denying a lot of players
a championship and you could argue that
carwana you know in his in his precise
style was better certainly than everyone
else in his generation at least for a
while
um and and I know Bobby's not the only
one who has that complaint but it's just
hard when stylistically for Fabi in
particular you're so similar to Magnus
he's just a little better in a lot of
those spots and also I mean this is a
banal point but carwana hasn't won a
game yet yeah and you know it's it's not
like he doesn't know that he can win I
mean he's beaten Carlson a million times
but you start getting under your own
skin you start getting in your own head
I mean 90 minutes have passed basically
without a win for Fabi so if he can win
this last game with black that'll
actually give him what Bobby's wife
tremendous amount of momentum Bobby's
white but yeah
oh I apologize yeah my point holds my
point holds and I you're you're avoiding
why did I think why did I think Carlson
was white I'm not totally sure so Magnus
is the one who gamits the pawn which
yeah Danny is even more impressive to me
the fact that he's up
four points and he doesn't just say I'm
gonna play a queen's gamma decline he
says I want to be up five points but I
apologize yeah I was gonna say my point
still holds that these types of
positions are still what you want if
you're Favi I think you need Dynamic
stuff in order to have a chance not um
you know like we said the nimsos that he
had us both black and white um but no
you're right it is impressive to see
Magnus going for this we see fobby
leaning in there Magnus letting his soul
glow there with the uh with the fro
yep I wish I wish I had hair like that
instead of the classic horseshoe pattern
I was born with I was born with male pod
male pattern baldness you've got nice
there I feel like I'm hair is one of
those things where you always want what
you can't get like people compliment me
on my hair but I really sometimes wish
for wish for straight hair sometimes I
feel like and you've got straight hair
you feel the opposite I want to have
Magnus to Sarah and magnus's raiding and
Magnus is everything yep
yep yep yep
um it's good to be king Magnus is black
here but Bobby okay you have a chance
you're up a little bit on the clock you
are up a pond for the record for those
keeping score
um it's an iqp pawn another iqp
structure geez yeah
these guys uh they like some iqp shout
out to winning Pawn structures by
baburin if you're looking for a book to
teach you how to play yeah Pawn
structures check that out
it's hard to find though I checked
Amazon and it was like it's out of print
I have a copy I have a copy here in the
office
um they don't make it anymore it's I
like I found some copy of it on like
Amazon selling for like 300 bucks or
something yep like it's just insane
um so if you can find winning Pawn
structures at some random bookstore
where they don't appreciate what they
have gobble it up because it's out of
print and it's fantastic
or sure and okay Fabi has managed to
wheel his way out of the unpleasant
position and now I I feel afraid to save
his Danny but it is kind of a game for
two results right now he's got the Pat
the extra Pawn on T4 it is also passed
but can he break down Black's incredibly
Rock Solid blockade that's going to be
the question of the day here of the game
oh light squares are defended well
computer didn't like 94 I admit I have
zero clues why maybe Magnus will teach
us
I think night night before looked pretty
unpleasant but anyways Knight before
threatened to Fork I think you're right
that was magnus's move there he didn't
see it Bobby doesn't give him another
chance puts the bishop on D2
yeah but are you really going to win
this against Carlson I mean do you
really have a chance here look at his
pieces
yeah I mean at this point it's funny
when you have a pawn that you kind of
wish you could give up like to open up
space I mean obviously you don't
directly want to and here you're
probably going to lose it anyway but
it's yeah this is going to be a dead
equal position
um likely a draw and uh with three
minutes left the only question is how
much time goes off the clock first
um will this be our last five minute
game before a break and in the 3-1
segment or will we get one more under
the wire I think they're going to find a
way to keep this game going if you're
fobby
I don't know I don't think you want to
have the black pieces in another five
plus one game I think you want to get
this to the break with minimal damage so
if your car wanna
almost just keep fighting try to milk
the clock down and obviously there are
still chances for white it's it's not a
draw just yet I mean black hasn't won D4
yet
yep
Bishop B3 and G6 Maybe
play Rook D2 if G6 and the Knight has to
move does D4 fall well it definitely
does the question is does white give it
away and then maybe get the Knight
around through G3 to E4 with a fork
thread on C5 and F6 is weak once black
plays G6 so some logistical concerns for
for Carlson even if he wins that pawn
yeah really good point
this night coming in to E4 you've got
other potential things so Rook T2 played
we'll see if okay Carlson's gonna go for
it Bobby right on cue follow suit
yeah
maybe F5 that's a Carlson type of move
Carlson likes to make those types of
moves yeah F5 keeps the pony at Bay out
of E4 and then we clean up on aisle nine
next move look at that Carlson finds it
the pawn the pawn fell off the shell can
I get a cleanup on aisle nine yeah
Brenda Brenda wait Brenda went to break
five minutes ago she just had to break
an hour before that listen I've lost so
many of Blitz Games and positions like
this against Magnus I feel like I have a
good grasp on what kind of moves he
likes to play now 92 Bishop C4 and then
if y doubles on the D file the bishop
can return to B3 so we actually could
get a repetition here yeah if Fabi
doesn't find anything better and I don't
see anything better right now
92 Bishop here threatens to take the
Knight so Fabi defends and we could get
a bit no this is this is Carlson saying
he's playing for a win down a pawn he
definitely keeps alive hopes of winning
especially given fabi's clock and yeah
tendency to overpress in in the match so
far
well now you gotta take on D3 can't
allow that pony to get 95. yep
so
we should point out that D4 was
Untouchable because of the rookie D1
yep if Knight D4 there was a big old pin
big old pin
yeah all right
CA to Knight T5 coming
ah Black's playing for a win no question
about it no question about it crazy
black is down upon playing for a win
night better than that big Pawn I mean
Bishop on C3 and that's exactly why Fabi
gives it up right on cue he says you
know what I'm tired of these Shenanigans
I'm gonna give up the pawn to get a
better minor piece
and
Carlson takes it otherwise the pawn
would have moved to D6 and this is
definitely heading toward a draw it's
also going to be the last game of the
segment which I think both players are
happy with
officially unless something shocks Us in
the next 20 seconds as you can see the
clock counting down above magnus's head
so I'm not sure who who's playing for a
win here exactly at this point maybe
bishop D4 Bishop B3 can be considered uh
Fabi can try to get his Bishop around to
G5 the H4 Pawn is a weakness
okay this is
I don't know about this move yeah I I
was highlighting the same thing that I
thought at the very least now you have a
Target if you're fobby but instead
he plays G3
okay those will be split right no now we
have split pawns which is a target for
black yeah but with the board being this
open you can go rookie two check and you
can even just go back to D2
he's trying to ambitiously you get a
checkmated
in okay you cannot play Rook h8 if
you're black that's actually very
important that Bishop on D4 yeah I mean
I'm sorry we're not laughing about them
and uh Rook C7 I don't know
Rook C7 I I do love laughing in the face
of danger and walking up the board
because you know last game of the year
Dan candle anything back now exactly
Rook C7 King G5 Rook H7 and if you play
H4 you would have gotten made it but
it's a moot point he's doing this a
little differently
that night's coming to E6 careful now
okay run back
and then maybe oh he goes he's going for
it
he's all in all in but Rook T8 is
possible here yeah but okay he trades I
was gonna say could he have moved and
then tried this idea he's still going
for it G5 was interesting but Carlson
again just playing with an abundance of
caution he cannot lose because the F
Pawn cannot be attacked yeah and notice
that the pawn is the opposite color
square of the bishop even worst case
scenarios are likely drawn for black at
this point
yeah yeah this is this is a dead draw on
either side can make I mean black is
really the one pushing here but
I don't see Carlson winning this
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
I know
that's yeah
not yet
okay well
time is ticking right we're gonna have a
very quick break of course after this
but you're not going to go anywhere fans
or Don you will hunt you down and find
you yes I will he's a lot like Liam
Neeson when it comes to tracking down
people and leave his chest shows
he's uh that was a taken reference right
of course it was done you don't always
have to doubt yourself when I when I set
you up for a pop culture home run you
hit it out of the park buddy love taking
it's actually one of my favorite movies
love taken well Bobby feels a little a
bit taken aback
because now that he's down 6-2 he's not
even keeping Pace with smarter chess
predictions which which had a 6-3 score
uh at this point with a four game
deficit what do you do to shake yourself
up heading into 3-1 Donya
well I mean it's hard to answer that
question because Bobby has played well I
mean he's played high quality chess he
really hasn't plundered a lot he's just
sort of gotten outplayed I would say
just try to go for tactical openings the
speed is going to be crucial in the
three plus one segment he's gonna have
to keep Pace on the clock and and try to
avoid those time scrambles because
Magnus has been getting uh the edge in
those scrambles all throughout the match
and it's hard because again I don't feel
like Fabiano's been playing bad which
makes me feel even worse I almost I
almost would look at the 6-2 score if
these guys were totally stylistic
different say you know maybe the next
time control brings a different story
but right now it's really hard to see
where Fabi is gonna find those those
cracks in the shield that is uh Captain
Norway I guess if you will being Magnus
Carlson all right well either way
regardless of the match score we know
you're having a good time fans and if
you are enjoying this online speed Chess
Championship we know you're going to
enjoy the fide World rapid and Blitz you
do not not want to miss that event which
is coming up it is of course one of the
most highly coveted titles in over the
board chess Magnus Carlson has won the
world with championship five times a
little bit of a memo that I think people
forget but he'll be joined by Hikaru
Yanda Palm Desi and so many others of
the world's top players going going at
it there in Kazakhstan this event begins
Monday December 26th and you can catch
all the action here at twitch.tv chess
Donya we are live on twitch.tv slash
chess we're going to be live for at
least another couple hours so don't go
anywhere fans when we return Magnus
Carlson and Fabiano Carr want to head to
the 3-1 segment and we will be right
back
foreign
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest bustles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh we missed it
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the match
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be electric
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God yes it is he's
gonna make a queen the stakes will be
high just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back everyone it is the 2022
speed Chess Championship it is presented
by nobody actually Yours Truly does
anybody Don just hair and we are back at
the speed Chess Championship we've had
the 5-1 segment already start and finish
with Magnus Carlson leading by a score
of six to two Dania uh we uh we aren't
totally surprised but it's been
impressive by the world champion thus
far
it's been impressive is it
understatement and the fact of the
matter is that when Magnus brings his
A-game nobody can compete that's just
the reality of the Chess World and it's
frustrating for Fabi because he he has
brought his A-game as well he's played
good in the opening he hasn't blundered
I mean he's kept things pretty clean but
it just lacks that just that extra
little bit of fuel in the tank yeah the
lack of OMG moments in this match so it
showed how high level it's been right
you said it no eval bar craziness no
blunders yet Magnus getting the edge
just barely in every game let's take a
look at the insights of these two
players and talk about the edge that
Magnus had coming in very similar in
that it was only slight right they both
played more than a thousand games the
average accuracy so slow close but
slightly favors Magnus we see
percentages slightly favoring Magnus
overall and I guess that means maybe we
could say we predict a little bit of
Magnus being just that much more
accurate than than Favi yeah I mean
these stats are pretty mesmerizing
they're pretty similar uh in terms of
the total games and the average
accuracies and even the percentage I
mean both of these players are Elite but
um Fabio the wins by flag that has shown
that he has improved his speed and his
clock management tremendously over the
past few years and that is one bright
spot for Fabiano caruana in this match
thus far he hasn't lost a single game on
time and when he has it's been because
of the position on the board and that
boats pretty well for his chances in the
three minute can he be Speedy can he be
efficient and he can he find the right
balance between intuition and
calculation
I love that call out because of all the
stats there that maybe favor Magnus
slightly if we're looking for a call out
that tells us hey it's not over it's not
over it's not a doula okay it's not over
if you're Fabiano caruana he has
improved on the clock lately he did
complete a comeback against Arjun
irigaisi in the bullet when a lot of
people were looking for that match to go
the other way and Fabi get better as the
time control gets faster we're about to
find out
we are indeed and obviously Fabi you can
just kind of sense the frustration he
wants this thing to get underway and uh
the first couple games of the three plus
one portion are going to be absolutely
huge because this is where Fabby can set
a different tone okay it's a clean slate
it's a different control the score is
kind of wiped in that sense and in the
SEC you've got to play well in all three
segments so what can Fabi bring to the
table in these first two games
well we see a rui Lopez now for Magnus
on the white side this is the first time
we've seen Magnus get a Lopez yes for
sure um we we have seen a Petrov but
here with the Lopez what uh what will
these two guys bring us in theory that
has been played very much you talked
about this position being played by both
players in the match-up from Dubai the
2021 World Chess Championship Carlson
versus Nippon machine and Bishop C5 that
is the Archangel variation which has
been uh incredibly hotly debated now for
for well over a decade and Fabia has
been playing it for well over a decade
and it's it's a very risky line but it
has withstood the test of time and it's
also withstood the Advent of of new
computers so it's actually a very robust
variation and Carlson playing it very
positionally you often see white going
C3 D4 that's the principled continuation
Magnus a lot more modest puts the pawn
on D3 and kind of plays this almost like
an Italian
yeah
and uh the Italian meaning referencing
the pawn on D3 versus the C3 and D4
normal Spanish for everyone I'm
translating for everyone who doesn't
speak just as good as you like me and
and that it's the Italian means the
structure is flexible because you
haven't committed to a Spanish c3d4 you
still have this Square for the Knight
and even this square and so these
positions as you as you've said many
times John these are favored in modern
chess because of the flexibility they
offer that there's more ways to maybe
catch your opponent in just a a subtle
subtle maneuvering mistake it's kind of
interesting that in Russian um you don't
say Rue Lopez you can only say Spanish
and I started to realize that not
everybody actually knows what Spanish
refers to I think RI Lopez is more
popular
uh in in the English speaking chess
terminology so it's fun that openings
have different names across different
languages anyway totally unrelated Point
does not really confused at all the
discussion that stat was completely
irrelevant I'm gonna tell you that that
was just you know good
oh my God but all right Queen E2 is
played The Rook comes to Da quickly talk
about these structures real quick Donya
the fact that black allowed the bishop
to take on C5 to play DC is is all part
of the plan for black to kind of over
emphasize control over the D4 square and
the D4 break right
yeah I mean I will point out as sergeant
Silva silverwater says the speed by Fabi
has been great in terms of the structure
it's like the definition of you know
both the strength and a weakness at the
same time but the structure is ugly
you've got the doubled C pawns I mean
you can imagine white putting a bishop
on D5 and attacking that C5 Pawn later
on in the game and things are exploding
on the king's side but Black's got that
immense control over the DeForest score
but did Fabi just Overlook a beautiful
tactical shot by Mr Carlson look at that
move Knight G5 is a double attack on F7
it also opens up the queen to hit H5 for
all visual Learners out there get your
coloring books out I'm about to draw
some arrows
um you could play Knight F4 and gain a
Tempo on the queen but you lose F7 with
check but can you take it with king of
fa what can we go to the Batcave here
analyze this thing what is going on in
this position I have I have zero ideas
oh my God Knight F4 magnus's idea might
be Knight takes F7 of the queen sack
what you're gonna sack the queen with
check I think I'm gonna do just that my
friend and queen F6 for example
not types d8 check and hey you get a lot
of business for the queen
you we've got to work on this it was uh
anyway all right Knight G5 I I dig it
and if I take you just take here
we're gonna have six Knight F3
and white is if if we see a queen sack
in this game Knight G5
Knight F4 and Knight takes F7 when do
you let your queen get taken with check
for a minor unbelievable this is an
unbelievable idea and there's also like
C4 in this position you could sack it
back but I don't think that works out
for black Bobby's calculating this you
can just you can just sense the wheels
turning in his brain and Knight F4 has
been played and Magnus goes for it oh my
God we're seeing it on the board ladies
and gentlemen the exact line predicted a
queen sacrifice
black is okay here but obviously we're
all kind of you know on the edge of our
seat with that sacrifice of the Queen by
Magnus but but what a crazy idea that is
just
but unfortunately the fireworks have
subsided and you know I think black's in
the driver's seat here to be honest
Danny
yeah I mean the eval Bar says black
should be in the driver's seat you have
a queen for a rook and a knight if we're
doing exact comparisons
um
so Bishop E6 here comes to mind and then
maybe a uh long-term plan to harass
White's Queen side if I'd be doing just
that and he's doing it even more
concretely
yeah
this is another chance for a Fabi this
might be actually his biggest chance of
the match because he's completely better
he has Magnus reeling
yeah the C4 was a very good move by the
way if the Knight took everyone the
bishop hung if the bishop took the B2
Pawn fell so the bishop had to gain a
Tempo but now on Queen G6 you have a
thread of Bishop H3 and Magnus goes for
this with nice C4 all right okay 93.
Rook maybe bring the Rook into the game
if you're fobby maybe Rook have fate or
even H5 is the kind of move he likes
okay
a rook and a knight and a pawn for the
queen that equals nine points but again
the queen better most the time because
of the ability to flex her power with
one swift move Target things on both
sides of the board the rook and Knight
have to have optimal coordination at all
times to compete and now notice that
Queen takes E4 runs into Bishop C2 so
that's not possible Black's only chances
to attack the king side because White's
structure is watertight but if Fabby can
get the pawn to H3 which he's gonna do
that's gonna provoke weaknesses on the
king side and in a Time scramble there's
nothing more difficult than playing
against a queen that's running amok
a great town population US
Bishop C4 I I don't think you oh he does
trade I was gonna say three
okay H3 G3 no 93 yeah I mean h takes G2
that pawn isn't you can't move the Rook
move the Rook but where do you put it
yeah and and then while Fabi is
gathering sorry well Magnus is gathering
this pull and fobby's gonna go after the
e-pawn that's exactly what I was gonna
say
I don't know it looks like white might
have a fortress here but it's easy to
get forked and Carl I mean carwana's
gonna try to restrain white spawn's
first order of business second order of
business is to use this majority but
that Knight on E3 is a monster Danny I
think Carlson is holding this I was
gonna say the more I look at this I
think it's more likely that that Carlson
wins look at the mutual time pressure
whoa okay now it's very reminiscent of
the Carlson nepo game from the world
championship yeah yeah yeah this is wild
look at this oh look at four if you take
it 95 oh so close to winning what a fork
but carwana stays on top
okay there's G5 coming you have to be
careful he puts the Rook on G4 now oh
what is going on five seconds four
seconds
oh my God yeah I don't know I don't know
that either player wants a draw no
Carlson is definitely the one playing
for a win here I agree given the time
scramble you go C5 there's Queen G1
though picking up the pawn
oh
Queen G1 Here Comes The King
it's going to be over this is just like
Carlson nepo and he's just pre-moving
it's over dude the night the night is
such a monster
wait he just needs to cross that last
hurdle here
and he's seven seconds one second for
car one wait it's back to maybe a
Perpetual check no no there's no way you
can no way
no more checks that's it and tonight
next to the king putting on putting on a
clinic
the night next to the king is so hard to
deal with when you're the queen because
it's just constantly guarding every
critical check you want to make absolute
savagery and and this is where I mean
you just cannot you cannot lose games
like this if you expect to stay in the
match I mean it was again a two result
game and again Fabi gets over ambitious
and then again he panics in time
pressure but then again we have to give
credit to Magnus for why right I mean
Bobby's pushed because he's down in the
match he has a queen he has to push
there but the dynamic of The Rook at
night we said they had to coordinate
well to hold with the queen and that was
about his optimal coordination as we've
seen maybe since Carlson's victory over
yonda Palm Desi in a similar end game of
course the past ball was on the king
side over there but but my word
and honestly this is why Magnus is the
goat everybody at the top level can play
a brilliant game at their Peak but it's
these kind of gritty games that Magnus
always seems to pull out which which is
just perhaps even more impressive Danny
just the way that he adapts himself to
the uh demands of the position and the
way he handles those equal positions and
squeezes out every single chance
Alexander alakyne said you have to beat
him three times opening middle game end
game it almost feels like you have to
beat Magnus Carlson seven or eight times
to actually win the game yep
oh man
indeed indeed I'm just I'm so impressed
by the coordination I want to go over
that game with the rook and Night Out
playing the queen like 10 times to learn
something that was just so impressive to
see two pieces that aren't known for
their coordination when play is on both
sides of the board they're not known for
keeping up in an open board game on the
diagonals they literally don't move on
diagonals very good that talk about the
school for The Rook at night but for
kids who who don't move on diagonals
good you know but he does but he does
position us look at this sound
population us another extreme stack now
now Carlson's just toying with him he
was playing with his food here
he's got it he's he's got a compensation
for the exchange that a pawn is a calf
who's wandered a little too far from
home gonna rope it rope it back soon
here Queen a8i he highlighted it he
played it before I can highlight it
um
but even if the Queens come off black is
actually in good shape here with the
exchange side
yeah I mean he's got the pawn Phalanx on
the queen side and actually black Mike
wants an end game here white might be
the one who wants to keep the Queens on
the board to give himself at least some
attacking chances but Carolina's worse
again I mean he's just slipping this is
starting to to get away from him
completely now
yeah
if you put the Knight on D7 okay he goes
94 aggressive stuff
yeah 94 Bishop D4
ABC one's B5 yeah
baby baby
but F3 the Knight just goes back to F6
and the bishop bunny Seven doing a
a phenomenal job just protecting both
Knights actually Stellar defensive
effort there
and I want to point out another thing
Danny F3 Knight F6 Queen C2 Knight C5
takes A6 and look at the placement of
the queen on Aid how it guards the only
weakness in the position just Artistry
from Magnus Carlson in terms of how he
positions his pieces
again agree town we got to come with a
new way to say this we're starting to
complete each other's
sandwiches
ah
so cute
so wholesome oh Knight E6 he's gonna
pick up the bishop so that A7 Falls
um
yep
yeah I'm gonna need you to come in on
Saturday
um no lumbric here High
um
almost 17 000 with us on Twitch I
haven't checked on YouTube thanks for
being with us on this
what day is it
Tuesday
it's Tuesday okay so we got title
Tuesdays running in the background
mm-hmm
um I don't know who won the first one
don't know who the first one twist
ending probably Hikaru
I think I was actually struggling this
time which I know these words are just
don't roll off the tongue at all because
you never say that but this is like one
in a million
okay but Queen C2 does keep the C6 Pawn
uh
you know I'll notice for a little bit
longer but of course Magnus could just
play Rook C8 and we're back to
variations where we can take it with the
pawn if we want but you got to be
patient I think and also let's remember
maybe you don't even need that pawn to
start advancing I was just going to say
if you get the bishop out of the way
push them baby push them baby
push them baby indeed and you can just
see the Evo bar continuing to drop and
drop and Fabi has not whipped up any
counter play on the king side he goes
back to the queen side and he's clinging
to the pawn on A7 like you know someone
clinging to a piece of Jetsam in the
ocean I mean the moment that pawn
disappears you get washed away by the
waves and I think that's exactly what's
about to happen
The Rook comes to A1 the queen will
swing herself over okay maybe maybe B7
or D7 first I guess you got to hold the
pawn
but
is there even a threat of Discovery here
I guess I guess he decides to go to V7
yeah it's more that you needed to defend
the pawn yep
and Knight D4 C5 of course you didn't
want to take on D4 because then the E
Pawn would reposition to D4 and slow
down the progress of black spawns and
note that white didn't want to take
black would happily have taken but at
the pawn they're reinforcing this
massive Pawn Center
and uh
and it's a tough it's a tough position
currently for white 45 minutes left in
the three minute portion what can Fabi
do to break the spell change the
momentum ah Magnus it doesn't flutter
anything no Rook takes D5 but such a
hidden threat and he saw that instantly
I mean it plays rookie gating just he
just constricts you and he strangles you
and Bobby has to try to go after that D5
Pawn somehow maybe take some Queen F5
can be considered
yeah
oh okay
these pawns are
you're threatening to play B4 a lot of
positions and this bishop is actually
trapped okay so Bobby fixes that problem
But Here Come the Pawns
oh no to uh
too much C3 Magnus ignores D5 I don't
know if you should have done that Knight
C7 there might have been a little more
safe time is time has become a factor
here it was just a clinic but now we're
in a bit of a scramble blunders are
possible they do happen Magnus is human
what can happen now
well if you play C2 you allow Bishop to
B2 we saw similar scenario in an aronian
Hikaru game yesterday he never had these
menacing pawns but they're actually hard
to promote
so yeah can Carlson came back and won
that game with all the fans versus The
Rook it was crazy oh Queen A6 is
clinical Queen trade allows these pawns
to get moving again yeah
forcing the ladies off the board put the
British okay wait rugby one rugby one oh
my God forgot about Bishop he's got one
second I I forgot about his clock oh my
God and now carwana's in the driver's
seat but it should take C3 he's giving
it back just to get rid of the pawns
practical chess makes sense here still
winning chances for black though because
of the weakness of the dark squares King
G7 and look at Carlson driving the pawn
down H4 not missing a beat what did you
just doing what was he doing with his
life Bobby looks frustrated he's he's
I mean he's lost his mind F5 was winning
The Rook there
yeah he just looks totally dejected me
too oh my God Danny G2 won The Rook
oh my God what's Happening Here
oh my Lance this is a dry seconds one
second oh my gosh this person might lose
Knight F4 King G3 King G4 oh my God
Poppy's back in the driver's seat
unbelievable and Carlson literally had
G2 there winning the role yeah winning
The Rook one of them before okay one of
the few oversights this is gonna be a
draw yeah should be a draw okay unless
we get a blunder by Favi and we see a
night bishop checkmate okay I was gonna
say he can he can sacrifice the rook and
get a draw anytime
oh my gosh shake your head everybody and
I feel dirty after that like watching
saw for the first time I'm like was that
okay did I just do something wrong
watching that movie
that just feels feels Wild
and Carlson is very disappointed and
this is Magnus for you in a nutshell he
is such a perfectionist he's up by Five
Points he still hasn't lost the game in
this match and yet it it eats at him
that he didn't convert that into the
full point it really does he's not just
trying to do that exaggerating thing you
know where uh you know you're kind of
fake fake disappointed he's really
disappointed that's what he expects from
himself
well and I was distracted there because
when Fabi let that slip I I was looking
and again shout out to to reading body
language that Bobby hates but seriously
that was you could really tell he was
just ejected he was just blundering he
trapped his own Rook Magnus misses the
opportunity to win it both F5 as you saw
earlier and then G2 were available to
Black yeah but okay like I said we want
to put that one behind us just like most
of Carrie Carrie Elway's films just
kidding I love Carrie always shout out
to Robin Hood Men in Tights
is that the movie with Mel Brooks
oh my God Donya have you never seen
Robin Hood been in Tights
no but is that the right is that yeah
Brooks bad news in a good way right
that's the best scene from the movie
you're giving me that Blank Stare Danny
I don't like it
no it's when it's when uh you know the
the the whatever a courier comes over to
Richard III and you know he says his
brother is there uh you know to take to
take over and the king is played by oh
who's this comedian who is in Curb Your
Enthusiasm what's his name the
black-haired dude yeah hilarious guy
maybe someone in check and let me know
and he says can you give me maybe if you
give me the bad news in a good way it
won't be so bad anymore and then he's
like
well I have some some very good news
your brother is here and he's gonna try
to kill you and take over and then
Richard III's like why are you laughing
it's all the bad news in a good way oh
my gosh watch it on YouTube okay sorry
baby that was a long way no this is
great I love it I love that we're uh
we're yeah and and John John Stewart is
no it's not Jon Stewart
no it's freaking ah I'm Googling I'm
Googling we'll find it we'll find I did
I got outplayed on that I agree no uh if
not only did Dania deliver
with recognizing the uh oh the movie but
he actually remembered one of the most
iconic scenes from it so touche don't
you I have to hey I have to give credit
when credits too
shame all right
Magnus Patrick Stewart Patrick Stewart
yeah Jon Stewart different actor no no
anyways back to the game back to the
game I'll find it Magnus is um back to
back to what he does right just just
grinding out
positions with slight edges and BD
by the way Richard Lewis that's the one
Richard Lewis it's funny I wanted to say
Richard but then I was like no because
it's King Richard yeah but his name is
also actually richer yeah but yeah okay
so who's in the driver's seat and why in
this end game usually it's Magnus if
it's an end game and I think this is no
exception Danny yep the a file is
controlled we talk about open files
especially when there's only one or two
here white is in control of wherever the
access points might be
okay
do you change your big decision whether
you want to take with the pawn or not
nope
but now the light squares are weak and
Bishop B4 incoming potentially
unfortunately for Favi as much as those
crazy scrambles have also gone magnus's
way this is not a recipe I think to make
a comeback at this point because I think
that these are positions where Magnus is
right at home they pretty much guarantee
we're gonna milk the full time off the
clock and uh if anything white has a
tiny Edge
I really really feel strongly that Fabi
has to mix it up against one E4 yeah and
he's gotta maybe play a French maybe
play a sicilian sebastianikov just get
fresh positions the only chance at this
point for Fabiano might be to take
Magnus out of his comfort zone in the
opening yeah
well again and it started out
differently the D4 prep apparently for
Favi was maybe a maybe a little bit
better I mean I like the positions he
had both as white and the nimso and the
one he had in that game one is black and
I know I keep referencing it because
frankly I haven't seen enough positions
that were dynamic in a way where Favi
was was playing with winning chances
okay there was the Queen the queen game
I guess in the last game but
unfortunately Magnus was the one who won
that oh losing that game is is just such
a Backbreaker
okay I like how fobby's playing this
though
improving the king the F5 Pawn is weak
the bishop pair hasn't spoken yet not
doing anything impressive
let's see what's that James burrow in
the chat says Magnus out of comfort zone
where would that be yeah you'd kind of
have to go to the edge of the Earth to
get Magnus out of his company Zone
through that yeah that
yep indeed
Bishop D3 played hitting the B5 Pawn
probably your best hope if you're black
is to just sit this one out and be like
all right how are you winning
yeah rookie eight also merits
consideration and he plays it I'm not
sure
if this reduces White's winning chances
or increases them yeah I do think black
should be able to hold because there's
really no breakthrough on the king's
side this is what I think is going to
save Fabi here is there any F4 at some
point
I mean I think I got King 6
I love it yes okay
um oh wait a second now it's like that
trade at all every Pawn on a dark Square
makes Donya a dull boy this bishop is a
beast and we'll find if it gets any way
in Black Will Be black will be losing if
this bishop can somehow get it oh and I
just spinning up anyway
Danny the idea is HG Bishop takes G5
I've wholly smoked my brain is exploding
fgf six and the pawn promotes God
you have to play bishop d8 and then H6
breaking through again and suddenly
White's got plenty of winning chances
and you could play H6 at your leisure I
was gonna say oh he could he could have
even gone this way to prepare H6 and
force the black king to be in a less
less than ideal position
now two options here for Magnus broadly
speaking I like King G4 H6 and then King
H5 trying to infiltrate through the king
side he's gonna win this game isn't he
laughs
if anyone can but G5 what an instructor
point I guess we were we were kind of
focused too much on the queen side in
hindsight that was a really instructive
grip that white had and you always have
to watch for those shots when your
opponent has the pawns further stuff
everyone knows of like the three little
piggies trick where you sacrifice all
the pawns right and break through kind
of a similar theme in any of these
positions where you have much further
Advanced pawns despite it being
symmetrical you have winning chances and
the pot end game is losing yeah so can
Fabi build some sort of Fortress here
King G7 E4 King G6 and Fabi can move his
king that's big because oh the bishop on
D4 the pawn promotes
huge move think he's holding it I mean
Carlson's gonna try to get his King back
to F4 I think
yep now the E4 opponent has gone too far
dude he just never dies he just keeps
fighting and fighting and he just never
ends
what do you do now no you give up the
pawn and yeah you give your Bishop away
but it should be losing no this has got
to be lost
it's so hard to go back to G6 but when
you get all the way back what's the
difference
no tasty five try try to win this one
sacrifices f for C
um okay it should be a draw objectively
but I think Magnus is going to pull
through
King C5 King C5
it's it's over the King goes to D5 you
push to C6 and you force the bishop
trade it's a winning King upon ending
99.
this might have been the most
unbelievable game of the match Danny
seriously this has to be studied by
everybody who wants to learn something
about Chess after the match
this might be a game we asked Magnus
about too after the match in the
interview again I'm speaking a little
bit out of turn to say that it will be a
foregone conclusion that we're
interviewing Magnus but at this point
what we're seeing is
a Magnus who woke up after his match
with gukesh and brought his A-game and I
I don't I don't understand what you
would ever do to stop the guy right now
it's it's a total runaway train and you
just begin to see why exactly magnus's
dominated top level Chess at the hardest
time in history to do so for you know
something like 12 years at this point I
mean this is why Welcome to Hell says
Magnus because when he's on his A-game
you're busted you're filling the blank
yeah that's a backbreaker right I mean
not to say that the scoreboard was not
already massively favoring him but
that's a
G5 winning that game
I
rarely rarely the crowd is finally happy
Danny finally doesn't know what to say
Mufasa Mufasa
Magnus
deep breaths all these smokes shout out
to the yeah the guy who made that gif on
command on Twitter threw him a diamond
membership get his name but uh he made
it he did exactly what I imagined him
doing
it was perfect
indeedovich population two
indeedovich is that to give extra
respect the middle name vasiliovich
Vasily yeah indeedovich that's a famous
Soviet Grandmaster
all right we had everybody he was just
saying D okay we had another isolated
Queen pawn it is no more because it is
gone white still has the bishop pair but
Magnus Magnus happy now because upon is
a pawn and you can you can use it you've
got Knight A4 you've got a three on two
majority here
and I just again an end game that Magnus
can start squeezing he's up a pawn he's
slightly better and it's just a broken
record I mean it keeps playing the same
tune
oh
can he pull another one through here and
expand the lead to seven
very patient and this is just this is
this is tough you know I honestly feel
I'm
gonna gonna make a prediction that you
know will sound insulting to anyone else
who might have been Bobby's opponent but
I'll say this I think Fabiano's rapid
and Blitz has improved drastically and I
believe that that record he has where he
has actually never gotten out of the
quarterfinals is destined to change and
I think if he had faced just about
anybody else in the quarterfinals he had
a very good chance of getting through I
mean someone even with a different style
right even a guy like Hikaru who is
better than Fabi in these fast time
controls Bobby would even admit so I
think Bobby would have preferred Hikaru
right just someone with a different type
of of game than he gets that he tends to
get over and over against Carlson where
it's like he's beating ahead his head
against a brick wall you know and and
Magnus is just like Bobby but but a
little bit of an engine I think
sometimes that could be a harder
opponent than someone who's very
different than you
that's a great point and and if we're
going down that path I mean Carl both
Carlson Nakamura and Carlson is going to
be one of the most epic matches of the
SEC but again matches in over and not
only is it not over but let's think
about it this way 30 minutes left
caruana needs to start with one win at
this point forget about the meta
strategy I need to get it down to four I
need to get it down to five he just
needs to score one single Victory and
what this is really coming down to is
that he will need to be perfect in the
bullet segment he will need to mount a
five six game winning streak but guess
what Danny we have seen those types of
streaks basically on the regular in this
year's SCC so yeah we have you know so
not only should you keep watching this
match from the perspective of Carlson
just being an artist but a six point
lead is not insurmountable and Fabi has
the skill
to do something incredible we know that
we've seen it before yep
and you know the SEC is very much a
format for for streaking excuse me
excuse me you know you know bring your
green hat we're going streaking through
the gymnasium but no seriously like it's
a it's a format to put together shrieks
because your opponents don't have time
to gather themselves at least not till
the break and so if you can get on a
roll and get one game
that's when the the emotions can start
to get to your opponents so
unfortunately for Favi this is exactly
the type of game that that Magnus has
had all day he's in complete control
he's up a pawn and really playing for
he's playing for two results Magnus can
either win or Draw yep um but if you can
get a win
you gotta get gotta get that guy with
the big the big hair flowing from Norway
gotta get him rattled at this point you
just might need a blender you obviously
you'll need to get lucky multiple times
if you want to pull off the unimaginable
in this match yeah um okay but I think
this game should end in hadra but
Carlson's not going down without a fight
that B4 Pawn
can Carl want to surround it with his
pieces I think he's been able to do it
Rook B3 Bishop D2 Knight D4 he still
won't die
look at this
maybe F4 is the way he's sitting tight
Rook B6
okay King E7 is it F4 that he's aiming
for here a four of five
I think that might be it because Bishop
E3 to D2 Knight E6 jumps into D4 Danny
and
you might experience some problems there
yeah
yeah 405 makes sense and he goes for it
obviously if F4 and five in the night
moves you can actually immediately play
Rook takes V4 because of the fork at the
end but all right Magnus fixes that real
quick gets the pawn one square further
to queening
this is
a game that that has the potential to
turn around in mutual time scramble
obviously objectively black is doing
fine
but there's this you know there's this
danger of the king rook and Bishop
getting jiggy with it over here Knight
C5 King F3 and we're gonna get Mutual
liquidation and Denny
another thing that we don't talk about
is Carlson's incredible ability to know
when to bail out he just always seems to
understand exactly when he's likely to
start over pressing and at that very
moment he manages to bail out the game
it's it's this insane Sixth Sense he
knows when to bail out and when to step
on the gas pedal and he always seems to
end up being right yep yeah the sense of
danger right it's just something you
can't
you
you can't really teach it I guess I mean
I think it comes it comes intuitively
over time with all the other chest
muscles you've been building getting
stronger but that right as we were
highlighting it you and I were just
saying watch out king F5 like black
black is up a poem but this could turn
around and it's like Magnus like here's
the call and it's like you know what I
could blow this one not even going to
give my moment my opponent a moment to
breathe
um
on that note I believe we're going to be
taking a moment
in this 3-1 portion for a quick break in
the 3-1 segment the players will gather
themselves grab a quick drink maybe a
snack or two because that's what Brian
Boitano would do we're going to take a
quick look at the match scoreboard Dania
it's nine to three right now in favor of
the world champion and uh
what are you gonna what are you gonna
get for lunch later
what am I gonna get for lunch later oh
my goodness I I don't even know what to
say I can't think about anything except
Magnus Carlson's performance in this
match I think I'm gonna have a nice
Shawarma sandwich
swarm up wow you always the reason I ask
is because you always just come up with
like it's like you have a lot of variety
in your menu and all right Magnus has a
lot of variety in his games he's getting
it done no matter what it's uh as you
said welcome to hell as he would say to
his opponents when he's playing well
it's like you uh you joined Magnus
Carlson in the ring when he's got his
A-game and you are in for a long day but
all right Johnny we still got a lot of
our day ahead of course what will happen
as the time Pluto gets faster can
Fabiana car want to do the unthinkable
we're gonna find out and of course we
have interviews ahead so don't go
anywhere 16 000 plus a few on Twitch and
many more where that came from the SCC
will return in just a few
foreign
[Music]
okay when I say chess the first word
that pops into your mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
it's like bright is good right yeah then
yeah the instant swipe right okay super
into that right I'm into it you're ready
that's probably whatever the swipe is I
don't not interested so you're not
interested in chess players I'm not into
chess players are on Tinder oh I get
that I in fact that checks out if I ask
you to name one chess player in the
world can you name a chess player
yep no not gonna honestly Joy Capital
boy
if you name five other world champions
in the next 15 seconds I'm Gonna Give
You fifty dollars
Bob trashy holgar
Carlson and
on holy [ __ ] you get 50 bucks dude oh my
God we just lost 50 whose idea was that
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we are back now here in another
quarterfinals matchup for the 2022 SCC
International Master Danny wrench
alongside Grand Master Dania narodisky
and Fabiano caruana is not really liking
the score he has alongside the world
champion right now
oh my goodness Danny I'm I mean this all
speaks for itself Carlson's plate speaks
for itself he has been absolutely
perfect and when I say perfect I
literally mean he has been perfect
I I don't disagree with you this has
been maybe the best performance we've
seen from Magnus online in in a long
time uh for those who don't remember the
last time Magnus played in an SCC he did
not win the event he actually lost in
the next round uh the semi-finals he
went down against Maxine Bashe the grav
something he'll have a chance to uh
to write this year right right the ship
If he if he can go all the way and and
uh we'll see what he does but right now
he's definitely making a statement in
this match versus carwana but guess what
I pointed out that he should consider
playing a sicilian and he's done just
that so I like the way Bobby has started
this game he's getting a fresh structure
and a totally fresh position he's not
playing e45 yeah and uh the problem is
Carlson responds to the rosalimo and
Carlson's just going to kind of Coast uh
or try to Coast the rest of the segment
he's going to play solid openings
and he certainly doesn't mind it if all
of the subsequent games are drawn
how many isolated Queen pawns it's crazy
does it take to win an SEC match I have
no idea but we've been we've been giving
a lot of instruction about how to play
these positions and the players have
been uh executing on those ideas of
course here again you see a piece in
front of the weak Pawn this is maybe one
of the most
common thematic fundamental things you
got to do against an iqp
um generally the player with the
isolated Pawn needs more active pieces
in order to compensate for the weakness
and Carlson who's had most of the
isolated Pawn positions today he's been
doing just that just look at look at his
pieces I think every minor piece is a
little better for white than the black
counterpart and uh
and we'll see what happens another
isolated Queen Pawn here we go
but another
ugly
ugly position for black I mean I don't
exactly know
where Fabi has gone wrong but you can't
play with that pawn on E6 Danny that is
a that is a catastroph that is a really
bad weakness and the Knight on D5 it
ain't gonna matter if you lose the pawn
on E6 if you lose the anchor yep
structurally Black's best move is
pulling backwards F6 to F7
yeah exactly I mean black is better
instantly yeah the moment you can play
F6 F7 everything that was wrong is now
right but you can't do that so instead
he runs the king away and I takes D5
Knight takes D5 just wins a pawn
straight up A3 is also a move that pops
into my brain all right A3 looks you
know A3 looks tasty I guess A3 Knight
takes C3 and a takes B4 is an option and
then A7 actually might fall as well so
Magnus spoiled for Choice here 94 also a
possibility if you want to keep the
tension but I I definitely think he's
going to take on D5 one way or the other
and he does and just maybe that was
inaccurate
probably A3 I think was was maybe the
best move but he doesn't even need the
complications because a big exchange by
the way if you take with the Knight
first
no okay but no no why can take D5 and
then take B7 you don't even have to take
everything on D5 and let black get some
compensation with the open Bishops my uh
my mouse has become very very active
here apologize it's very very jumpy
Bishops don't move like that I've
learned wait what
I mean clearly I was poorly taught
clearly
um
carwana taking a think yeah
if if you take with the Knight white
will trade and then I think I think take
B7 and not D5
um exactly exactly exactly exactly Jen
yeah yeah Knight takes okay and indeed
we're gonna go for this line and Mistake
by Fabi should have played 65. he sees a
massive exchange opportunity oh my God
what an idea he's gonna exchange
everything and then B7 is going to be
his for the taking regardless of where
caruana puts his Queen this is clinical
surgical filigree precision and he's
gonna get another Pawn up position it's
funny because
we were evaluating the obvious tactics
and probably white could have taken B7
but that that type of spotting and then
and then seeing the the most efficient
way to kill your prey is is often what
shows Magnus being in top form you know
rookie one Danny I mean he just he
doesn't stop every move is more precise
than the last
it's relentless
Relentless is probably the best word to
describe it
um and again you can outplay your
opponent by playing good moves but the
best moves and and this Relentless
accuracy is what just makes your
opponent feel hopeless
yeah and Fabi just leaning back I know
we don't read body language too well
but uh speak for yourself it's
unmistakable yeah but but here here the
body language is totally unmistakable
he's just telling himself am I really is
this really happening am I really going
winless here because again Fabby himself
has played some very clean chest Annie I
don't think we've seen a single one move
blunder you know save in in time
scrambles throughout the match and
somehow he's down by seven points he's
about to be down uh he's down by six
points about to be down by seven
I mean even in the time scrambles we've
seen very very few these guys have
played some some of the highest level
accuracy chess in the SEC thus far maybe
ever I mean we'll see the stats and
maybe maybe get back on that one to
confirm that it's not just commentator
bias because you know Dania and I can
get caught up in our emotions sometimes
we are guilty of that but it feels to us
like this chess has been just so high
quality but Magnus is like bringing
World Chess Championship form back right
he's bringing sexy back today he knows
he had an opponent that he deeply
respects here in carwana and he showed
up
he showed up indeed and look at how he's
just decorating his position driving the
pawn up to H5 and the feeling of
hopelessness is it reaches a peak when
you're a pawn down against Magnus with
no counterplate you just know that
you're gonna mistake eventually make a
mistake eventually and he's exploited I
think Rook to B5 here yeah I might
basically win the game I've been
highlighting it because A4 was okay he
goes for this more oh because he's got
A8 in the end
I guess he thinks his Pawn structure's
favorable maybe takes in Rook B5 usually
defending the pawn from the side is
ideal here but no Magnus actually keeps
the Queens on the board interesting
decision making here I guess it doesn't
spoil anything okay seven still looks
better yeah so much better and Bobby
down to 20 seconds so Magnus still in
the driver's seat I thought A4 was going
to be followed by Rook B5 he does
eventually play it now and we're gonna
see the Queen the queen rook and these
pawns all come together so that you can
push safely
yeah I mean any Queen end game is lost
at this point
you probably are fine to trade Queens
but Magnus kind of slow rolling it yeah
just has to find a way to push that pawn
to A6 yeah Rook B7 Rook B7 A6 A7 you
don't even care about H5 anymore because
the a pawn is too fast not even head to
the delivery room it is a baby girl on
A8 a new Queen enters the arena
I mean this is Michael Jordan at this is
Michael jordanesk
we really I mean we know he's good but
seriously this is we have not seen
Magnus play
uh this well I mean in in online events
he's been playing title Tuesdays
recently obviously had an SCC before
this but this is
this is uh
it's why they call him the goat you know
this is crazy stuff maybe getting ready
to get a sixth sixth World Bliss
Championship headed to uh Kazakhstan
so the way he's playing right now I mean
he's gonna go whatever 25 of 25 however
many rounds there are the world champion
is in a state of flow and this is just
amazing to watch honestly
seriously
we talked about how he's won five World
Blitz championship titles I think it's a
fun fact that goes underrated about
Magnus Carlson's career because you have
other things to focus on also a
five-time classical world champion also
the highest rated player in history but
talk about how difficult you think that
feat is right we know right now he wants
to win the SEC before heading to
Kazakhstan and write the right the wrong
that was him getting ousted last year
but I mean in comparison and this is in
no way meant to you know to disparate
Chicago Nakamura who was arguably you
know the most celebrated especially
online Blitz player of all time and one
of the one of the freakish talents ever
to play the game Hikaru has never won a
worldless championship title right
because it shows how hard that event is
the gauntlet that is winning that event
Magnus has won it five times it's just
crazy when he's on form yeah when he
doesn't win we're all shocked and over
the board Blitz there I think there is
no it's beyond compare there's really no
argument to be had Magnus is the
greatest Blitz player who has ever lived
Hikaru is the greatest online Blitz
player who's ever lived and I would say
that nowadays it's important not to say
well that's better than that or online
better than OTB both of these are
incredibly impressive Feats and you know
these two forms of the game they coexist
but in terms of sporting achievements in
terms of the consistency of his success
Magnus Carlson has his record is
unimpeachable yep
well right now Magnus is uh like you
said in a state of flow and uh this is
this is a unique position I'll say we
have not had this structure on the board
in any game thus far and I will say
despite the email more saying it's equal
I'm not a huge fan of black setup here
Magnus is going to have to write the
ship there you would much rather move
the Knight and open the bishop uh be in
a different spot so we'll see if Bobby
can capitalize on that
yeah this this feels a little bit dicey
for for black I mean Knight C3 and D5 is
coming to a theater near you and even if
black moves the Knight away from C6
which is quite typical white could
actually still go D5 and Sack the pawn I
would do that automatically and then
play Knight D4 I wouldn't be able to
resist the temptation to play D5 here
just just do it nothing to lose at this
point go oh yeah he does it boom the
Knight comes in if C5 watch out for
Knight F5 as you said
okay E6 is coming E6 and Bishop H6 this
is it this is a game where Fabiano
buckles up passenger speed belts
and uh
Clicks in right this is a Danny wrench
type of position so thank you for that
I'm beating a dubious attack for both
sides or
[Laughter]
no but seriously I love I love the way
fobby's playing this and
you got to get a job you gotta get a
Fabiano Victory a comeback has to start
somewhere
yeah it does and wow Carlson just laughs
in his face in castles he's like I don't
care about anything and C5 and exchange
sack
amazing play again just amazing
yeah he's gonna make this super tricky
as we said he's not gonna roll over but
he is down a minute and he's down in the
position but Fabiano
has to find the right approach to
convert
he Retreats the Knight I kind of like
the patience yeah I love the way fabi's
playing this game he's played
phenomenally and he's only better by
like point six points which is the
ridiculous thing about playing an on for
Magnus Carlson
yep
and now you don't even want to take the
exchange because you feel like that
that's what Magnus wants to get relief
yeah you want to keep the tension but
okay he goes for it which
at a certain point I guess you kind of
had to but at some point this bishop has
a ton of compensation
and some Verve in that move Knight A4
he's going after that week B6 spawn and
trying to squeeze the knight in through
B6 to D7 but Carlson says no no no I'm
keeping the queen side alive dude
such inspired chess this game where has
this been yes this is the move B4 I'm
making a note what was the opening he
played in Italian a much more aggressive
one than normal with the early D4 strike
someone uh make a note to Fabiano that
you need to rinse and repeat this one to
avoid dandruff
[Music]
what kind of shampoo do you use a great
hairline
um but we already talked about that Rook
to C1 oh Bishop B3 he's working the the
knight in The Rook Magnus winning back
some material he sacks The Exchange back
karwana is going to be up a pawn here
Queen takes D4 and we're gonna get the
type of end game Carlson has had all
throughout this match but with colors
reversed can Fabi do what Magnus has
done all throughout I like keeping the
Queens on the board though I think this
is what you do in magnus's time pressure
I was gonna say especially with the time
pressure from a practical point of view
wait Danny he had he had some tactics
with Knight F4 and queen B3 check
instead Fabi forgets about Bishop D6 and
Magnus is stabilizing again he's better
now instead of Rook C7 Knight F4 kicking
the queen from her Central Square he's
gonna lose this one again this bishop is
perfect where it stands and Fabi is now
retreating and re-maneuvering
but to no avail here comes the a pawn
just like in that end game remember when
Fabi was pressing for a win and suddenly
magnus's Pawn appears on A2
exactly what happened there suddenly
look at the clock
pressure temperature
there's a crazy idea with A3 and a queen
SEC but Carlson does it clinically
oh wow A3 Rook D4 take B2 I just saw
what you were talking about that would
have been fun but Magnus takes the safe
approach
Mutual time pressure commences
a b a b it's a piece
a b baby Bobby will just no he can't
take him beat you because rookie won the
bishop guard at H2 I wonder if black
missed that
what is going on now craziness I'll tell
you what's going on Carlson's winning
he's gonna take he's gonna win the queen
with check and the a pawn is too much
and the King just advances toward B3
how does it look so simple in the end
it's unbelievable just like he's he's
calculated all of this ever since the
Queens are on the board and Carolina is
is incredulous
he's just like how what do I need to do
to beat this guy and he wins again he's
not even drawing these games he's flat
out winning every position or Worse
better time pressure who cares I'm
winning them all
that moment when he played Rook C7 if he
had played 94 but again there's many
moments where we say just that one move
but that's like that's that's that's
like the story of the match right as you
said you gotta beat Magnus not once
twice and three times as Al Yohan once
said you got to beat him seven or eight
times oh Lord this is crazy
what was that
what
was that
oh Lord
just like a Southern Southern expression
it's like oh my it's like a more common
version of Oh My Lens
I I didn't know I for a second I thought
you were slipping into Barkley there for
a minute but it was a bad Barkley so I
didn't double down on it all right stop
stop barking at me Danny we've got
hanging horns which is the the closely
related cousin of isolated Queen pawns
so a similar structure that we've seen
all day these are very fun positions as
far as you know really understanding in
an instructive way that both sides want
different things
um here Magnus playing very aggressive
just saying I'm not even gonna mess
around and let you develop I'm
immediately maybe relocating my pieces
for a king-site attack
or
yeah a healthy dose of nasty here on the
king side for white but where is the
fuel Danny I don't see where the kicker
is I mean Bishop D3 you point out but
black deploys his Bishop to B7 and the
hanging Pawn structure can become a
serious liability if white doesn't
produce anything specific on the king
side I think Magnus is kind of playing
Hope Chest a little bit here
agreed
foreign
does it look super solid but I also
don't see a great move for
I mean you got to be a little careful
here
you don't want to put the bishop on B7
because of tactics I think
on E6
yep and Magnus is sinking into a new
thing
yeah what's he doing
got head in hand
yep
coming up with dubious tactics okay
right away Queen H3 uh oh what now
though this is the critical moment Danny
can he sack on H6 somehow
I think it's just gonna be a big
simplification the queen kind of defends
C3
but if everything's traded in Black
plays Rook C8 black just has a
positional Edge
yeah but Bishop takes H6 is actually not
as gimmicky as it looks and it's not
that easy to stop
well now it's on the board okay it was
an option but probably Queen takes C3
was the response
yeah Queen C3 oh yeah and The Rook hung
in the corner so that forced to Queen
trade yeah still you should keep an eye
on Rook G4 and when you're playing
Carlson at this point you're in your own
head right every every idea looks like a
three-headed monster
but you're up a minute on the clock
so
yeah so Now's the Time if there was ever
a good time to start a comeback it's
right now
so Queen to C4 player I don't know what
to say man
A4 immediately responded by Carlson
it's funny because if you if you start
sliding in yeah Magnus kind of smartly I
think heads back if you go all in for
those kind of
you know speculative tactics over there
you probably you probably see it
backfire so instead Magnus brings the
queen back to F3 where you can kind of
start defending
yeah I mean listen the pawn on C3 much
like the iqp pawns that he has had is
very well protected right it's like that
Knight on F3 defending the pawn on D4 so
yeah Carlson makes these types of
positions look incredibly easy when he's
on the black side when he's on the
defending side he makes it look
incredibly easy as well Danny yep
so whichever side you're on you're
damned if you do and damned if you don't
give me some good news if you give me
bad news in a good way it might make me
feel better so can you say can you say
that it's impossible to beat Magnus in a
different way please Jenny what the
bestness in the world's here is so
encouraging your doubt 11 3 of the match
and you haven't won a single game yet
and you're three out two hours into the
match
why are you laughing why are you
laughing to present the bad news in in a
good way that's what you're trying to do
I'm following instructions am I in oh
man
all right well
the time Advantage has all but
disappeared only 20 seconds now white
with a little bit of an edge the d-pawn
because all could also be traded for the
a pawn and we will have another draw
Fabiano caruana if you're just tuning in
still yet to get a victory in this match
which just tells you the level of focus
Precision desire to win desire not to
lose Magnus brought to this match and
there's been several games where he
could have pushed a little more but
smartly since the danger has not given
Fabiano any reason to celebrate at all
and listen look at this he's better
again he's literally F6 right somehow on
the on the strong side of this position
when as when the queens were traded
Danny it looked like there would be no
Universe in which black would ever be
playing for a draw and yet that's
exactly the case after D5 oh he gives
the check on G5 he wins The Pawn on H5
I thought he was gonna play D5 too
because me too but he finds Rook G5
instead which is
and now he's gonna squeeze out the three
on two for for an eternity
six minutes left in the three minute
portion we are more than likely going to
have at least one more game of three
minute before bullet happens but
but man this is just
it's been this has been tough a tough
day for the American in the office
the American office was way better than
the British office
I just I haven't seen either office the
office the office I you can keep
repeating the name of the show but I
still haven't seen it the office like
the show was Steve Carell the show says
yes you've never seen Wilson I know very
well from his chess Endeavors but I've
never seen the office know I'm more of a
um
I just don't like comedies I'm I'm you
know I'm dark I have a dark mind I like
Black Mirror
okay got it I don't know if the chat
needed to know that but Carlson look at
what he's doing Rook C4 another Artistry
type of move because Bishop takes D4
there was mate on C8
oh wow
G6 Rook C8 here he goes after Black's
King rooked h8 maybe oh my God he's
ready
and the king is trapped mating that's
ensue there's F6 there but you might
lose the Rook on D7 if you open the
seventh Rank and I'd be running for dear
life he's got two seconds though Magnus
you gotta move quickly you might lose on
time trying to mate him he's weaving his
tentacles around Black's King Bishop G5
and if five there's F3 and G4 and it's
over three and G4 Bishop G5 with me he
has to give up the exchange and so oh my
God and he might still get mated on e4
yeah oh he's pretty move GF okay you
have Rook D1 oh
that was sick oh my God that was nasty
oh what a mate that he weaved how often
does a king get checkmated in the middle
of the board on F4
it's just
getting out of here yeah can I just like
throw down the headphones and walk out
now I
wow I feel like I'm throwing my
headphone back like my hair back like
just ridiculous this is ridiculous show
me some nasty from Magnus Carlson he
pre-moved G takes F5 he saw that a mile
away
that was that was so crazy that was sick
that was uh it was dirty it was all the
adjectives before we start saying
explicitives and Magnus Carlson is up
nine games in this match
no but this is just it's almost like you
think you can't play any better you
think he's achieved everything there is
to achieve in a match and then he comes
up with another incredible narrative
he's worse than an end game bang he's
slightly better two moves later bang
he's up in exchange bang there's a
mating net just one thing follows
another and yeah you do sympathize with
Fabi I mean this is such a hard position
to be in Danny where he's just pummeling
you
and I've pointed this out before when
you play a Swiss tournament and you
start losing games you get easier
opponents this reminds me of when I
played the 2015 US Championship the
worst Tournament of my life I lost three
of the first four games and I've got
Hikaru Nakamura in round five here you
lose three games to Magnus and you've
got Magnus Carlson you're losing him
again guess who you got Agnes Carlson I
guess the same storyline we had in the
match with casuals are running away like
there should be one one time in SCC
where like Danny gets to ring a bell and
then Magnus gets up and I get to play 10
games in a row yep
at at this point no you would win Danny
come on give yourself a little credit
give yourself a little credit girl
exactly that would definitely if I if I
had 10 in a row at this point it would
make this thing a match dude he's better
again Magnus winning again he's gonna go
H4 and smash through the king side
yeah the H5 Pawn is hanging though
but the B5 full board awareness you're
gonna take on C4 and have all kinds of
problems which is why white did not take
H5 the queen needed to stay defending
and here comes H4 just like he said
holy smokes is this guy in the zone or
what
yeah playing on both sides Danny B5 and
H4 look at that Exquisite Pawn play as
he provokes weaknesses and overextends
White's Queen after G takes H4 Knight G6
you're attacking the F4 Square the H4
pawn and you have the pressure on the C4
Pawn which means a move like Queen G4
which would otherwise stabilize the king
side now allows the queen side to cave
in
on the the opening plate in this game
too is a sign that we've kind of gone
Full Tilt here
um and not the uh not the poker style if
you're fobby this is Full Tilt because I
don't think he's bringing openings at
this point that we're prep he's playing
nothing wrong with the English but I
just I I find this position to be one
that isn't isn't necessarily one that he
drew up at home if you know what I mean
I believe I do Mr Wrench
geez
God
and imagine if he wins this game
sticking the landing he'll be up by 10.
he has not lost the game now Danny I
wonder if there has ever been an SEC
game SEC match where one player has
never lost I'm 99.9 sure I'm sure that
that has never happened and so I mean
come close to happening you're wondering
another good reason to stick around
besides the interview we will likely
have with the world champion assuming
the improbable doesn't happen
I I don't think we've ever seen that by
the way I will make a very you know bold
prediction we are not going to see that
Fabiano is going to get a dub in bullet
mark it down it will happen there's no
world but but at this point the fact
that we've even gone two segments has me
wanting to call up stat boy give me
Vaughn let's go check in the bullpen and
see what stat boy has because
have we ever had a five and three one
portion before someone got a victory
that already is a question no I'm almost
positive there was that Hikaru feta save
match which I think started with an
adoption
but I'm pretty sure that Vladimir stole
a game at least one game in the
three-minute portion okay now this game
by the way has gotten really sharp all
of a sudden Carlson has kind of let
things slip on the king side yeah and
Fabi is the one striking on both sides
of the board now can he deliver
Ed yeah this was
a way to spice it up for sure
but still you feel like When the Smoke
Clears whose King is going to be weaker
probably whites the G file is open oh C
file is open
yeah 95 was a step in the wrong
direction yeah literally he goes goes to
the e-file instead
but it just feels like it feels like
this king is about to start feeling the
draft too many windows open
yeah rookie three is on deck and that's
a pretty devastating move Mufasa
oh God every one of his faces always on
the perfect square Danny that night on
G6 the bishop on G7 controlling the pawn
on D4 which defends The Rook on E3 it's
mesmerizing oh man the third is Queen by
the way he sees it but that was just
Queen E6 threatened Queen A2 and rookie
two for the record Rook B2 stopped both
uh Carlson move here would be like Rook
G8 like a slow creeping move that sets
things up yep or queen D5 Queen D5 Chan
exactly sometimes when you just don't
see what to do Jan you just improve your
pieces exactly exactly precisely
okay or even A6 should be considered to
disrupt the pawn on B5 whoa Knight
Carlson movie expected what is he doing
oh my God look at this
but it can't take because Queen E3 and
then Rook f8 after King F5
it's a great practical attempt Bishop E5
comes to mind he's down a rook no he's
down the exchange okay dear Lord Rook G8
would be an Intermezzo and then maybe
Queen takes E5 to set up discovered
attempts no I was gonna say the pawn
recapture if rookie a king of four Queen
E5 was made yup but he doesn't go for it
Queen F6 E7 oh there's a check on B7
that he wanted to avoid yeah yeah Rook
C3 first both players under 20 seconds
Knight takes D3 doesn't quite work the
F5 Pawn hangs with check there's a queen
coming to H4 check at a moment's notice
it's starting to turn around no magnets
have gone too far with that exchange
sack we'll see Bobby okay
Queen B5 Queen to be fine C6 Danny Queen
C6 is going to trade the queens and
Black's gonna win again
I don't think there's a way to stop it
holy smokes too many pawns for the
exchange
Magnus is gonna no he just takes D3 even
more direct Queen F3 check minimum it's
over rookie five Rook F1 mates mate what
a fork
that's not even fair you can't even lose
the pawn because work F1 would have been
mate
this is just absurd
this is out of this freaking world that
night on F4 and the pawn on H5 white at
all three of his heavy pieces on the
king side Danny black had zero heavy
pieces on the king side there were no
checks
this last little combo right look at
that position the fact that Bobby
couldn't take this Pawn because of mate
oh
wow no but this is this is getting crazy
well
at this point it's about it's about
playing for playing for pride playing
for the fact that there is money on the
line in every single game remember that
and well obviously these guys don't
necessarily play for the cash they are
professionals and four grand goes to the
winner four grand for every single game
you win is up for grabs
um which means every game is worth you
know a decent amount of cash I also went
to the school for kids who don't math
good so I'm not going to pretend to know
that math off the top of my head Donya
but at this point if you're Fabiano's
coach you're just saying get in there
Focus one game and get yourself your
first Victory listen you're Brazil at
this point losing 6-1 to German or 6-0
to Germany you got to score the honor
goal and listen there is hypothetically
enough time to play 10 games I don't
think fappy has given up and
hey we've seen all sorts of Unthinkable
things I've been in the Chess World a
very long time and I've seen the
craziest things happen so you owe it to
yourself just from the perspective of
watching Magnus put Artistry on the
board but also from the perspective of
maybe expecting the unexpected the
unbelievable to watch these 30 minutes
of bullet well and the unbelievable
might be there's two unbelievables that
could happen one an improbable comeback
or Magnus Carlson is the first ever
player to win an SEC match without
without losing a single game because
that is what he is on Pace to do right
now all right we got almost 20 000 of
you on Twitch and I'm sure every single
one of you will be tuning in for our
next state of chess.com this show is
coming your way on December 21st it's
our quarter four uh event and it is uh
probably our biggest ever state of Chess
that we've ever had tons of
announcements come in of course all the
Community Q a you can ask for with yours
truly so please tune in we have some
very very special guests who will be
joining our show to talk about these
announcements that we're making uh and
of course what they mean for the future
of the chess community and for chess.com
so don't miss the show it's December
21st at 10 A.M Pacific Time right here
at twitch.tv slash chess I don't even
think Donya knows all the stuff we're
announcing he doesn't he doesn't I'm
speaking for him
um
you don't right it
I don't no okay know what I mean I I
don't cool so you'll tune in okay great
um all right
everyone else uh don't go anywhere
continue to tune in we have the bullet
ahead then of course we have an
interview with whoever our Victor is
it's more from the 2022 speed Chess
Championship when we return
[Music]
Damon's Legacy is built around his
passion and focus
that academic component yeah you'll get
there in time
but what we don't talk about is the
impact that it could have on your
character
you know what what's the level of
confidence that you can Infuse in a
child who grows up in a single parent
home and don't get to see their dad
so if I teach him that he's the most
valuable piece on the game and in life
how will I change him
what about that young Queen you're gonna
need courage because you're a young
black or Latin Queen
this culture and in this community and
in this Society things aren't equal nor
will they be balanced but on a
chessboard you are the most powerful
piece
[Music]
on a chess board there's equality
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we are back getting set for the one plus
one portion between Magnus Carlson and
Fabiano caruana Danny wrench alongside
Donya noradinski it's been a long day
it's been a day of uh amazing chess I
don't know that we've ever seen the
world champion put on a show quite like
he has today in any online event or
maybe regular chess event ever done you
and that's saying a great deal because
the world champion has been putting on
shows for well over a decade and a half
now yes it's three to three there's one
small difference Carlson has a digit in
the 10th place that's not zero yep and
he has not lost a single game yet for
those of you wondering reasons to stick
around uh it's not just maybe for the
improbable comeback we'll see what Fabi
can do and have to start right away but
it's for the fact that Magnus Carlson is
literally
making history uh in in in this match
right now so and we're uh
we're about to make our way to the one
plus one portion uh the players I don't
believe are back at their chair they're
taking an extra long break probably
going to grab themselves a banana
because that's what I would do if I had
my way
um before we check out all the things
that makes Magnus Carlson great is
sometimes you're just you're sitting
around Donya and you're wishing that
someone that a banana would just fall
out of the sky and be delivered to you
oh my gosh that's Epic
where are you magical banana Angel fairy
thank you girl damn girl yeah girl that
looks delicious oh my God it's so fresh
I love it
banana time
mattress went to get it
I'm ready
thank you um let's let's talk about how
good Magnus is oh he's back in his chair
we were going to look at his insights
card where he's good at everything but I
think he's ready to show us that he's
good at uh he's good at the fastest time
control well listen I mean Fabi has not
pulled out a single one of these time
scrambles as we look at magnus's player
card and if this continues then this
might go all the way until the end of
the match but but I mean look first look
at his chest outcome Blitz rating he's
almost at 3300 only Hikaru has achieved
3300 plus and that for like a span of a
week I mean his ratings are crazy his
strength is everything and I mean his
weaknesses are nothing
32.79 by the way
that was the rating he had coming in to
the start of this match which is why we
had it listed at 32.79 on our insights
card that's actually still his rating
right now so he just played uh what what
was it third you know 13-3 and he's not
gaining rating 13-3 he didn't gain any
rating points that that shows you the
highest rating is but that's actually
that's actually fascinating that his
rating is the exact same that it was
coming into the match
um given how many victories he was able
to rack up against Fabiana who's also
over 3 000 inputs I mean he needs about
60 bullet points to steal number one
um
and the way he's playing I don't
remember what fabi's bullet rating is
but it might happen
he's gonna say he won't be able to
improve his Blitz rating from here on
out because he's uh
he's now playing bullet but Magnus
Carlson in the fastest portion
we'll see what we'll see what he does
here now we really see the gloves coming
off in terms of prep it's time for Sharp
crazy spicy stuff I like what Bobby's
doing no matter what happens mix it up
let's go
yeah I mean fappy playing a modern we
we've seen him resort to this opening uh
before in these must-win situations he
has to be literally perfect he's got to
win every single game and then some and
there still might not be enough time for
10 games I mean yesterday Hikaru and um
icaro and aronian played a record low
number of bullet games I think they
didn't even hit seven
wow that's a uh that's using your
increment right yeah shaking what your
mama gave you there but a nice position
in the early going for Fabi yeah I like
it a lot all right Annie no no you you
uh you go ahead the Queen's sliding from
E4 to H4 the knights coming to G5 though
Magnus is going to try to turn this one
around in a hurry and go for checkmate
yeah I'm kind of overly influenced by
the eval bar here now that I see Queen
H4 I'm starting to get very pessimistic
and look at the clock already Fabi he's
falling behind on the clock
and he's weakening his dark squares this
not looking good anymore it's funny the
evil board likes black but I'm with you
I'm like Queen H4 like ah like here
comes the pieces like I'm gonna get
checkmated
but the thing was Queen H4 ran into
Knight takes C5 so Fabi doing a great
job of anchoring anchoring himself to
that E5 pawn and he's actually now he's
definitely better yeah now he's
definitely better
okay Queen takes B5 is that Queen gonna
get herself in trouble yes it is he's
like taking Pawns
how do you get the queen out how do you
extricate the lady like 19 seconds oh
you open up the pathway back to D1 wow
this guy is so slippery that's funny I
literally couldn't see a way to get the
queen out anymore
move the bishop the queen comes back and
suddenly
and then exchange sacrifice he goes for
the dark squares on the king side he
wants Knight F6 with mate I love it I
love it very practical chess
Here Comes Bishop F6 even first I think
no he goes with Knight F6 first and
Knight and Bishop H6 is a huge
positional tactical threat of course
yeah as his Queen before Queen is coming
to F4 another headshake from caruana
and it's going to be another one for
Carlson
magic of the position sometimes comes
out of nowhere when you're when you're
playing against Magnus it's just like
position gets away from you I mean
whatever he touches in this match turns
to Gold yep the Magnus touch today
or don't move it because that's mate
just you know let's let's be safe here
two seconds and Carlson has to give up
the D4 Pawn okay here we go flipping
around Bishop H6 is a threat by the way
that's a problem
uh wait
King H2 oh you can't stop Bishop H6 how
do you oh my God don't stop it it's
Unstoppable it should be because queen
d8 queen takes d8 and white wins The
Rook oh [ __ ] he's like he literally just
gave like a WTF like what the Fabi right
like what is going on continues we're in
adoption territory right now this is
nutty if if Magnus Carlson
wins this SCC without losing a single
game what will I do
I mean he lost to gukesh I think only
once or maybe once or twice in the
bullet
but this has been insane and he's got
another nice position out of the opening
yep no but now Fabi is just he just the
air
to make a bet to make a bet if if Magnus
wins an SEC match without losing a
single game for the first time in
history we will have made history here
together everyone
uh me and Donya have done most the work
you chat have also helped
um but we will well I I don't know what
I don't know if I'm gonna do everything
but we'll let twitch throw up a poll a
poll chat make your suggestions I'll do
something crazy it is snowing outside
really
well Magnus is just a freak right now do
you think it would be an exaggeration
and I'm I'm I don't mean to beat a dead
horse here you know we pointed out many
many times how great Carlson has played
I don't want to keep repeating myself
but do you think it's fair to call this
one of the greatest match performances
of all time
I mean I really think that's not much of
an exaggeration Danny look at this look
at this he won another one and it wasn't
even close well it's funny now now Fabi
is definitely experiencing some tilt and
we love Fabi obviously you know that
right he's a good friend and I'm just
hanging out with him in LA and Ludwig's
thing like I don't I'm just saying like
no disparagement to Fabiano but this is
just an absolute Slaughter and now
Fabian tilt but earlier earlier done
your father was playing well that's
what's so impressive about this there
were many moments where we wouldn't have
been talking about a storyline uh you
know of historic proportions Magnus
potentially not losing a single game
so whether fobby's on tilt now or not
the fact that we're even here talking
about it is mind-blowing plus given
magnus's Forum Today Show me a player
who wouldn't get crushed by Magnus today
like show me a player right and I'll
wait
because show me the money
I don't get that that reference went 30
000 feet over my head Danny yeah
um all right Magnus is on the attack
right now what's gonna happen next if
the Knight moves oh my God we've got
Knight H5 coming queen H6 and you can't
take it because H7 is made okay
that was the only move Knight G8 had to
stop Queen H6 I mean this is just what
happened in the previous game and he's
doing it again now he doesn't have the
dark squared Bishop this time but the
Knight is perfectly capable of handling
business as is the other Bishop which
could sack itself on G6 it's on by Queen
G3 is the kind of move Magnus likes to
make in these types of positions okay
Queen F4 even also good you're
threatening to just take and then win H6
which is why Fabi plays King G7
but you can't take F6 because the Rook
on C7 hangs yeah
not what the doctor ordered Chief I was
gonna say no can you just play G5 Rook
G3 and then King h8 maybe but Carson
will sack on G5 with Checkmate there oh
no Rook C4 also a good move
I like that Magnus Magnus slipping a
little bit here this might be the game
this might be the game
if Magnus is all in on this attack and
he slips up Bobby could quickly turn
things around white does have weaknesses
on the on the queen side
I think after Knight F6 to E4 white is
very much still alive
okay takes G8 Rook G8 Queen F6 he might
have to just bail out and try to fight
game no
no oh Knight C2 the bishop was pinned
he's always sacrificing a rook here he
goes again
here he goes again 10 seconds for Fabi
maybe G5 gosh
the fact that he was giving up the Rook
for Knight G6 this is wild okay under 10
seconds Magnus Magnus could finally meet
his maker here he went all in on this
attack I don't know that he's gonna pull
it off with four seconds I think he
might Queen E3 and he counter-attacks
the nine and he's getting out of it
again no King H2 what a move Bobby's got
the pressure E5 is hanging
and he should have captured it and now
Carlson's starting to push him around a
little bit
Knight takes G5 two second one second
the check is on the king is running F7
he goes for it 93.
no no it's a pinned yeah oh my God now
the evil bar is swinging
this one is running
we're swinging now we got our blunders
oh H4 is falling in the end Queen not
quite not quite
how is Carlson doing this he's still
alive he's pushing the h-bond and he's
winning after queenie's five is this
he missed it Rook F7 ended the game but
now
now fobby's turned it back around a
little bit not quite I think Queen G8
ends it oh Mike no he can take with the
cousin Rook H6
95. okay look out for Queen C6 and
discover checks no the lookout for Rook
takes C6 was a threat one second now
Queen takes a chain
I'm freaking tired of this my heart was
pounding too ladies and gentlemen I am
beyond words speech Beyond everything
right now
but this is absolutely wild all right
I'm all in rooting for the first victory
of the day for the Americans come on
Bobby let's go that was that was right
there
I mean he had that in the back he was
one move away but just black magic from
Magnus Carlson again
the H Pawn ran there were so many
opportunities that was one of the only
games we've seen with the eval bar
swinging which is crazy that it took us
getting to the bullet portion before any
blunder started happening in this match
that was just nutty
all right this is insane we've got a
pretty symmetrical position here
actually another nice position I think
for Fabi who can stick a knight on D5
when he wants to and he might do it now
no not yet I don't think I could
physically twerk for three minutes Chad
I don't think that's physically possible
for my body to do
um but I appreciate the poll another
Wonder Bishop C4 the Tactical sharpness
is out of wow Bishop G3 okay but in the
end there's a tactic here as well E5 for
Favi yup where's that Knight going if
you go to D7 B7 Falls that's the point
97 Knight D5 is also pretty terrifying
oh Knight D5 the bishop disconnected
from The Rook so 98 98 or Knight H7
oh this is close Fabby could steal this
one come on fobby where's the tactics
for three minutes
Queen E3 comes to mind The Rook doesn't
have a lot of squares maybe if Queen C5
you're Brook C1 so Queen E3 looks great
yeah maybe a slower move like B3 to
cover the C4 score but Bishop E6 I
thought and Knight F4
Magnus is all right here if he's careful
yeah Magnus is stabilizing again I would
take the bishop and we can go H4 Bishop
H3
wow H4 nice move white is better the E6
bonus weak keep the pressure keep the
fun
Yeah Boy definitely better here he
shouldn't lose this switch this thing up
to the other diagonal
hey how do you get in that Knight on f8
and there is no Checkmate thank you
Mikel towel
E4 arowana playing some excellent chess
this game yep
do you go B5 and try to use C6 or do you
okay he does
Bishop D3 setting up the battery but the
Knight on f8 Danny yeah such a nice
defensive piece it's guarding H7 yep not
an f8 there is no Checkmate that rhymes
for a reason all Rhymes are true
it's a truth again again it feels like
Carlson isn't even close to losing this
game he allows queen of seven oh my God
and Bobby's like the bleep no
you still have it with Bishop
it's over I think it is Knight G4 and
Knight T3 are both threats yeah the
bishop is pinned and the queen is
overworked she has to guard F2 and all
kinds of stuff Queen f94 check Knight G4
check first even oh my gosh Magnus does
it again okay how much time do we have
here
17 minutes for Fabiano to strike come on
bro let's go
I can't believe what we are seeing yep
Fabiano is not playing the worst chess
that I that I've seen in SCC at all
Magnus Carlos said it's just absolutely
on another level not just not not only
is he not playing the worst chess he's
still not really wondering Danny he's
playing very solid definitely not as
good as he's capable of not as good as
against Arjun no question about that
okay but he's playing very decent level
of Chess and this is just this makes
magnus's performance so much more unreal
because we've seen plenty of blowouts
where one side just starts tilting Mega
tilting this is crazy man
and he's losing it yeah he's gonna lose
his Queen he's on Pace to get another
dub right now Magnus
yeah
sorry I'm just I'm you're out of breath
I'm Shell Shocked breathe Grand Master
breathe it's okay
yeah Magnus Magnus outplaying him yet
again
Bishop C4 Queen
f34.8 me oh don't miss it Fabby don't go
Queen D6 here
okay Knight G2 hangs the F Pawn he's
just down upon
he will win a no okay I thought the Rook
would take an A4 but no
Magnus just playing simple chess now
he's won a pawn he's gonna hold on to it
Knight's better than the bishop given
all the different pesky weaknesses we
have here we've got
oh man I'm I'm just like
haven't seen Magnus in a Zone like this
in a very very long time
no there's a little bit about the again
the presence of mind he's had especially
when it's gotten dangerous to bring it
back
bring it back to neutral take his foot
off the gas never give Fabi a chance has
paid dividends over time psychologically
as well
because Fabi I think just feels so you
know at this point you're just
you're just disheartened you know
yeah not to be too melodramatic but but
there's just certain performances in
sports
that are immortalized forever and this
is going to be one of them their
performances that display the extent of
dominance that certain athletes have
that certain sports players have Michael
Jordan you can remember some games Roger
Federer or some of the tennis matches
where he wins three sets to nine and now
Magnus Carlson's match against Fabi is
going to enter the annals of these types
of matches yeah this is crazy F4 though
too
and if because if C6 there's Queen B6 I
think I think the threat is Queen B2 and
how does Bobby stop it
yeah yeah no he can't
he plays C6 but that gives a B6
immediately if you want to put your Rook
on it although there would still be a
four but look at the prophylaxis Magnus
just stops it in its tracks and says no
you ain't getting any counter play yep
rookie five Bishop B4 just kicks the
bishop ruthlessly Here Comes The Rook to
E7
two three pawns up Mufasa
this is like wow that was that was good
choreography right there you see Magnus
like
I think Magnus knows he hasn't he hasn't
lost yet I think Magnus is like dialed
bleeping in right now I think he's
adopted him and him at this point we're
rubbing it in by saying that it doesn't
matter the whole match has been one big
adoption
and this is it's frustrating look fabi's
had an incredible incredible career and
is an incredible player we we know that
Magnus Carlson is the the goat was
before this match you know
you know okay debates we can we can
start a goat debate and chat if you want
but
but this is just one of those days where
sometimes you just you just want to
forget about it the moment this is over
whoever's hanging with Bobby Assuming
he's playing from his home in St Louis
it's time to go get a nice meal
and watch a funny movie
tuck yourself into bed and you know
get some Thai food on doordash just uh
take a long walk realize that the world
is still spinning and your neighbors are
still mowing their lawn
and uh you know for the time being
businesses are still operating
so for Fabi he's gonna bounce back from
this but at the end of the day if you're
gonna lose a match like this Danny
there's no shame in losing it to Magnus
Carlson yep and he played really really
good chess I mean honestly like the the
early portion of this was one of those
where Magnus was just a little better
and stylistically we know Magnus has
always been a tough opponent for Fabi
but now then it just became you know
Magnus showing up they say classes
permanent form is temporary I don't
think Magnus wants today's form to be to
be temporary he wants to carry this over
give me my next opponent ASAP
by the way the insane Bishop C5 might
work out here for black it's a queen
sack and I think he's gonna do it he's
calculating it
go for it Magnus Bishop C5
he playset
oh my God you can't stop it you can't
stop it you gotta go oh my God
Bobby just shook his head it was like
WTO
it's over again look at this position
the bishop on G6 this is the power of
control over a certain color Square the
light squares are monopolized by the
bishop and the king is entrapped in a
crazy mating that Rook takes D2 and Rook
d8
or this
yeah and look at this okay five and you
can't stop checking me I'm gonna get I
gotta get out of here I'm getting I
gotta get out of here bye
I don't want I don't remember the new
rules do allow someone to resign a match
with 10 minutes to go I don't want Bobby
to resign because I want him to get a
victory because I don't want to work for
three minutes and he's going to get a
win he's gonna get away he's gonna get a
win come on
but at this point Magnus of course is
aware of the stat and trust me Magnus is
on a mission he is trying harder than he
would be trying if this match were tied
right now I think yeah and you know what
I mean and not because he's trying to be
cruel or he's trying to rub it in but at
the end of the game just is a violent
game and it's a game in which you go for
your opponent's throat and that's we
wouldn't have it any other way
yeah and you know it's not every day you
have an opportunity to to just
capitalize on on what is some of the
best chess you've played uh so you know
you build on it
yeah you have to take every game as
seriously as the previous I think he
would be you know a little more nervous
if the match was tied I'll say this but
he is trying super super hard not a
single one of these games is is showing
a sign of Magnus letting up we're not
going to see a bond Cloud here he's he's
he is going to drive this home
foreign
thing I think about Chess fans and and
chess players is that we're able to
simultaneously celebrate you know
amazing accomplishments over the board
and and sympathize with the player on
the other end because it's not easy to
be in Fabby shoes it's incredibly
painful and the pain is going to last
you know throughout the day and for a
while and it's it's sad to see him but
it doesn't mean that Magnus is supposed
to give him the win or allow him to
score an honor goal he's going to keep
fighting and keeping the merciless
killer he's been thus far as the match
hit it's the 10 minute mark
agreed and uh
I'll say too I mean the other reason you
don't let up is look these guys play
each other in more games and in more
matches than just this and I think
Magnus you know and his uh his desire to
to dominate his opponents and his peers
over the last two decades his generation
is very real you know I I mean that I
mean Magnus is obviously you know an
incredible star and known for his
talents and his genius but I think his
his competitive drive to win maybe
underestimated maybe people don't always
think about it but I think Magnus
appreciates his ability to drive home a
memory that Fabi is not gonna forget and
I think that he realizes this is a match
that he's gonna flex and not to say
Bobby's gonna let it distract him when
they play let's say in tata steel coming
up in January but don't don't
underestimate that Magnus knows when he
has an opportunity to leave a mark and
he wants to do it and it's one of the
things that makes him great that's the
truth it's one of the things that makes
him great is he has he has a Killer
Instinct oh a ridiculous Killer
Instincts and after I think I blunder
because Bishop D5 there is Ed
so let's I'm gonna wait until the end of
this game to make my point Queen F6
rookie eight checks H3 escaping the
checks and winning the game again unreal
Here Comes unbelievable 58 or Rook G5 he
goes Queen G7 and rookie five and it's
all over again
on there's adoption there's 3300 man
number one on the leaderboard is quaking
a matter of time
it's about 300 I do not believe Fabiano
is going to throw in the towel I think
he wants to play he wants to get a win
at this point it just it's frustrating
feels bad
GE for fobby
I was gonna make a point Danny that
every single time in magnus's career
that there have been grumblings about
Magnus is he on the decline is he
starting to show signs of age signs of
rust every time those conversations are
whipped up we see a statement
performance for Magnus Carlson like
clockwork I remember the grumbling
started again about a year ago he won a
bunch of over the board tournaments they
started up again after his performance
in AIM chess he lost to Duda he lost a
bunch of games and now we have his
performance first in the Mr dodgy
tournament and now of course in the SEC
so that right there is the mark of an
amazing athlete and I use that word very
deliberately because this performance is
an athletic performance by Magnus yeah
well said
and uh and uh he's also making a
statement I guess to anyone else who's
going to face him in the SEC from here
on out that he came uh he found his form
right
Stella has one in their backs I think
Magnus is more like the Taye Diggs
character and the Stella Got Her group
back movie
um you know what I'm saying right
yeah Stella yeah of course the the
Cleveland yes it was the movie I saw
just yesterday
um
wait isn't Stella in A Streetcar Named
Desire
hold on a second we have an advantage
it's clear for Fabiano we have Victory
we have liftoff let's go Fabiano Right
Here Right Now the a pawn is real you're
up 27 seconds this is completely winning
for white because black can't really get
to the C6 spawn Magnus is trying though
but maybe you should just send the a
pawn full send A5 A6 C7 I think Queen D5
was probably a little better
now we're
now we're seeing a position that
okay here comes A6
here comes the a pawn
in 4k7 Queen V8 wins The Rook I think
that's just a problem oh that's game
that's basically game wait a minute
let's not how does Magnus get out of
this yet Queen d8 A7 Queen A8 Maybe
A7 rookie
Queen B8 Queen Z8 take it and then take
the pawn on D5 is one option yep and
that's probably what you should do okay
he's gonna take D5 this way
just be careful don't blunder The Rook
on A1
I think
he should have traded Queens he's going
to lose the pawn now Danny yes Queen D7
oh
but then I guess
yeah Rook C7 oh my land she's holding
hey
yeah he should have played Queen to V8
oh my God come on Bobby oh no no no no
no and Magnus might be better if the
Rooks are traded oh my God he's a lot
better but it's gonna be a draw this
this was this was a chance this was the
chance I thought this was going to
happen I thought oh my God that was the
dub
I thought so too it was basically over
he was one move away I mean if he played
Queen B8 traded queens that end game
Magnus would have been dead in the water
now it's still it's still not totally
six I was trying he's trying destroying
F3 okay Allison gives away the pawn wait
a second
he freezes the king though this is just
the theoretical draw oh my gosh you
can't make any progress dude the
presence of mine for Magnus there I
swear he plays these end games like he
has the table base memorized like who
just gives up the pawn in favor for
group C2 like that like who he could
have gone Rook A5 he could have killed
it he didn't have to do that I would
have played Robert and I were talking
about that another session like you know
I haven't had a chance to talk with
Magnus about that but like his ability
to like like know a position like it's a
table base like you just go for that oh
that's just a draw I'm like what like
you just give up the C point and that's
the draw
was the wherewithal to realize that
White's King was completely cut off and
if White had gone F4 there then there
was a check on the third rank pushing
the king away and winning the F4 Pawn so
literally no way to make progress
and Bobby basically with two more
chances to win a game
is on the home stretch maybe depending
on how long this goes I mean Magnus is
yeah if you're just tuning in don't go
anywhere we have never had a speed Chess
Championship performance where a player
who won didn't lose a single game Magnus
Carlson has not lost today an improbable
fashion against the American Fabiano
caruana who has also played fantastic
chess but Magnus has been on another
level
absolutely unreal what we're witnessing
and and the moments like that Magnus
even when he's losing you you gotta like
you have to like double tap you know
with zombie land where you gotta like
shoot him twice in the head I'm sorry it
just got violent you ever seen you ever
seen double time when when you start a
sentence with you know in
probably in most cases the answer is
going to be I probably shouldn't talk
about it but okay zombieland's a great
movie it is rated R a full disclosure
and um I I apologize for that but most
you guys are playing first shooter video
game Sorry the dad in me doesn't like to
talk about shooting people but the point
is if you're killing a zombie kill them
twice that's the message of the movie
Magnus is like a zombie you can't just
kill him you gotta kill him twice double
tap
or 800 times like some of those in
Walking Dead that I've watched yeah
you've never seen Zombieland no I have
not and the funny thing is I love well
people know I love horror movies I don't
that's it's not a horror movie though
right it's kind of a comedy horror movie
is it Jesse Eisenberg yeah Woody
Harrelson who's a good job by the way
shout out to Woody he plays on just.com
regularly maybe he's watching the show
right now shout out to Woody a couple
I've watched a couple of uh a couple
minutes of the movie but another point I
was gonna make Danny
is that Magnus hopefully will be in a
slightly better mood in this interview I
something tells me he's just gonna be a
little bit happier this time around
yeah and you know we might talk to him
about her we might talk to him about
some of the games that felt like the
turning point I think that game where he
played G5 and broke through and would
look like a dead drawn Bishop ending
talking about a player who as you said
he is he is he has changed the direction
of Chess in many ways maybe one of the
biggest impacts he made in his legacy
will be that
he he doesn't take a draw just because
the position's a draw
ever
he wins games you weren't supposed to
win 30 years ago and that game with G5
where he beat Bobby was was in my mind
the backbreaker and and the the game
that really really set the tone that we
were in the uh we were in store for
something special today and not only has
he changed the way people play in equal
positions he is I believe at this point
undisputedly the greatest and game
player of all time
AAA
title that I think is completely
uncontested as it stands by anybody uh
either in chess history or in in the top
in the world top ten
well he's always
he might lose this end game but
no he's he's he's I think he's the only
one who can win this oh because A2
Bishop sorry I missed Bishop C3 to A1
block kid okay
oh my God he does it again
okay fobby has one more game one
opportunity mom spaghetti mom spaghetti
let's go everybody stop what you're
doing and root for Fabiano right now
not history
thousand of you let's go
oh my God oh my lands this is about to
complete the greatest performance in SCC
history by a country mile yeah and Fabi
score the honor goal
let's go Fabiano
one more one more game this is it this
will be the last game officially in the
match
Magnus wants this so bad trust me he
wants nothing more I swear to God
as this bullet portion has gone on
magnus's energy has become more focused
like he senses what's at stake here and
his opportunity to write history
and the title of greatest SCC in
parentheses match in history is not in
question but if he goes lossless that'll
also then become one of the most
improbable just statistically improbable
performances in chess history yep
consistency magic this has always had in
his career his consistency but it you
know I wonder what he'll say about it if
there's a there's a part of him that
feels with his with his experience in
his old age at the old age of whatever
he is 32 or something you know
um not meaning he's not really old
um like if if his experience is like
just showing his his awareness his
ability to just sense the danger the
fact that he can maybe finish a match
without losing a chess game is
absolutely mind-blowing it is and in the
Lex Friedman podcast episode is Magnus
forces the trade of Rooks and he's going
to be better with basically no risk uh
he mentioned that even though the extent
of his dominance hasn't changed in the
last 10 years his style has matured and
he made this point that his ability to
rebound and his his consistency is
actually improved with age and we see
that here I mean you have the feeling
that not only does he have the sharpness
and The Verve and the resilience but now
he's got the full maturity to to be just
unwavering in the way in which he just
keeps pressuring and keeps pushing it's
amazing amazing to watch Amazing to
watch
apparently not the best move though
Bishop takes A5
oh oh wait a second
okay Bishop did still he did still have
a chance to win there but even so he
will probably still draw this game
uh wait fabi's winning D6 though okay
hold on hold your horses do we have
magnus's he does not want this game to
get away from him Rook H2 I think might
Force King G3 and then rookie to know he
cements the white king
let's see this is probably good enough
oh okay two and the king is cut off
again yeah he's holding the king in in a
in a cage it's this you can even just
play King F6 or Rook D2
yeah or Rook D2
yeah it's a draw it's official folks
just hold it F6
I don't know about D6 but that does even
so The Rook can't afford to go for the
H1 because the a-pawn will Queen so okay
that does let the king out oh Bobby
doesn't take it oh because they'll be
checked by The Rook here
oh
Magnus Carl oh my God place the first
ever speed chess championship match
without losing a game and absolutely
blows Minds in the process I don't think
I've ever seen a performance like that
ever
neither have I and watching this live
not only a great honor to be a part of
this even tangentially but we see the
final score there it simply does not add
up it doesn't add up 22 to four
and four was the result of draws he
dominates across all three segments
Danny and the extent of his domination
merely grew as they transitioned from
five to three to one
and I feel like the the fact that it
happened again almost felt
anti-climactic because it happened in
this awkward King Shuffle but it's like
Magnus once again saw the future where
nobody else did he saw the Fortress he
could set up he also knew what was at
stake he clearly was poised and wanted
it
Magnus Carlson just did the unthinkable
statistic I wonder what the statistical
probability is that anybody will ever do
that again including Magnus by the way I
don't know that we will ever see what we
just saw happen in speech test
Championship future past present
whatever the time machine Multiverse
says I'd hate you Doctor Strange you go
Dania
yeah I I am speechless like you said
this is one of the most dominant match
performances of all time I don't care
that it's online Blitz online Blitz
right now is a full-fledged indicator of
strength these players take these
matches just as seriously just as
seriously as an OTB classical tournament
or an OTB Blitz tournament we saw Fabi
putting everything he had on the line
but he just caught Magnus on the wrong
Tuesday Danny the wrong Tuesday indeed
sounds like uh the title of my
autobiography wrong Tuesday
Life and Times of Danny wrench oh my
gosh I just I'm speechless it was crazy
I I'm I'm I'm impressed to remember
which games which game stands out the
most to me I kind of want to go into the
archive and and find that game where he
played G5 if we were gonna if we were
gonna discuss any game that uh that he
won
that game where he played G5 and
okay all right well I I apologize for
that wasn't sure if we had the interview
or the break but we're gonna take a
quick break and then we will be joined
by none other than the world chess
champion Magnus Carlson who not only
wins his match if you just got here
where have you been he does so in
historic fashion without losing a single
game Dandy and I will return with Magnus
in just a few minutes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
makes shows like this possible which is
why our twitch subscribers will never
see ads on chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone on this historic
day we still have 20 000 viewers just on
Twitch who tuned in for this interview
and that's because
the man who now joined us made history
Magnus congratulations on the win you
made history by winning the first ever
speech has championship match without a
loss dude once you got rolling what was
different today
yeah I think I managed to calm down uh a
lot better
um
um then I did the last time also
exactly what you what you mentioned the
uh undefeated record
um I think in these matches like losses
can and settle you quite a bit and there
were uh some positions that I wasted
where I was winning but generally out
and you don't but you don't lose you you
don't tilt and you know that
I have spent a lot
Magnus you displayed Mastery across so
many different areas from openings to
your defensive ability to your precision
and time scrambles what would you say
you're proudest of what individual skill
do you think you displayed to the
greatest extent in this match
I'm an obvious but about the fact that I
never lost some time I was close a lot
of times but I felt like I was generally
quite good at using the one second
increment and
I felt that very often when when we got
to the scrambles
um he would he would make this sort of
quick
obvious moves that were often that were
often wrong when he actually had a
little bit of time saying but I think
that's also a case of when things go go
around that's that's what happened uh
generally I mean most of the games in
these formats is going to be messy but
uh I was there was one game that I was
actually very happy with
um which was the first uh maybe not the
first but the the Petrov where uh I got
Knights uh against the bishop as well as
Queen and Rook
um in very symmetrical position I think
I played that game uh very well uh like
normally I'm not happy with
games but that's one that I was really
satisfied with
um
but yeah overall
um it was a bit up and down but of
course a lot better than last time and
generally at the level I aspire to be
honest
I we so many questions get to you
mentioned one game there's a lot of
games we could get to honestly we you
know we were fawning over all of them so
excuse me and and all of chat here by
about fanboying over yours yesterday
Magnus but this this really was historic
the rook and Knight versus the queen
game you talked about the Symmetry and
the accuracy Donya and I pulled up this
game here because it felt like at the
time this this was a game where a lot of
players might see this position Peter
out to a draw but how how early had you
spotted this G5 breakthrough idea
regardless of whether it's a force win
or not but the Practical pressure that
that then put on Favi to defend and what
would you say in this position was was
key to to pulling away the victory
I mean to be honest that's at this point
I was cruising a little bit just trying
to play safe take any chances that I
could that I could find and yeah
immediately when we got to this position
King C6 I was thinking like uh G5 was
tempting let's see if it works and I
mean I I did have I think like 48 to 50
seconds so the calculation like making
sure it doesn't lose was pretty uh
straightforward but um uh but yeah it
was a big mode it's very very easy to
play King F3 Guinea four automatically
here and then
um the chance is gone I guess it was a
draw later but all you need is um
just a little bit of um
of Hope there to um to make yeah you
just need to make sure the game
continues instead of
it
king of Threes met by Bishop d8 and then
all the chances are gone is that the
point
yeah
um
now you can just wait forever
got it
okay you played G5 John did you have
another chest I mean there's so many
games we we would keep you for hours but
Daniel what else would we will be coming
back to his brain about I'm going to ask
a general question about the opening
Magnus um first your general take on on
how the openings went and then more
specifically
um how would you compare the openings in
this match to what you guys had in the
2016 World Championship and did you use
any leftover prep uh for this match
uh 2018 much status
um 2018. Jesus it's been a long day
we've watched you win for so long Magnus
yeah
um
well I have to say that uh before the
match I thought the only chance was to
hit me in the openings especially with
the uh with the white pieces so I didn't
really think too much about my wife
games I just wanted to to be solid as uh
as black and yeah I played fairly
serious openings
um uh I mean this uh Marshall stuff is
obviously very similar to what I played
on the match against young last year so
um so yeah I definitely took too much
seriously in that sense than I wanted to
I wanted to make sure that I didn't put
us in the openings because I thought
this long side I survived the the
openings uh then I'm a huge favor so I
was I was happy with that he was kind of
moving around a bit but apart from
like that one game where he played the
uh Scorch gun but he never really got
anything anything you know special
yeah we you know we we nice to say we
predicted that this would be kind of
some heavyweight opening prep and let me
ask so you had a mindset not wanting to
be worse out of the opening but when
you're looking at the openings to bring
to an SEC match are you playing
different openings than you would in a
classical match or is that not part of
the decision it's just about the quality
of the opening you're not choosing based
on the time control
I guess it's right I was trying to play
fairly simple positions
um
relatively relatively technical often
symmetrical positions I thought those
would suit me well because it's often
pretty good in complicated positions
where you can use this calculating
ability
um
but as blank yeah I was just trying to
apply openings that I consider sound but
in in that sense there was no difference
from
um Magnus we have another feature chat
question I asked you the exact same
question after your gukesh match did you
uh what was your routine like before
this match and did you change anything
up as compared to the the match with
gukesh
yeah I changed uh a little bit
um like last time I had
uh I had one uh big meal and one like
relatively small meal before before the
match that was that much was also two
hours earlier I this time I wanted to
have two big meals uh just to make sure
I I retained energy all the way
the routine different or not was
obviously effective today I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask a question from from Robert
Hess who wants to know whether you watch
the Mogul chess boxing event on Sunday
oh yeah I did uh well I didn't watch the
last uh last couple of
um of cards but uh did watch the uh
the big uh chess funds uh and um
yeah it was uh I'm obviously a good for
for learn study
uh that he lost so quickly but what I
mounted was
it was incredible I mean
to be honest I go up to that point
um it had not been tremendously exciting
but
um
that and then the
um Andrea Dina fight afterwards like it
was just too
um
amazing shows of entertainment in in a
row like I was like it was pretty late
here
um I gotta say but I was just literally
off from from the couch cheering along
no I I I was too and I I have to ask the
follow-up just because that way you can
you know set the crowd to rest would you
ever consider something like that even
if it wasn't chess boxing a physical
match with a chess match combined
I'm not gonna say a hundred percent no
uh okay because uh who knows like
worth my
mindset will be in the future but at the
moment five minutes
if you if you had if you had to choose
was there someone you would chest box
besides besides me
obviously all right oh I don't know uh
uh that we would have to to see but um
yeah don't count on it
maybe you'd hit Lauren strand when he's
down yeah the uh
[Music]
I agree that the mod performance was
crazy Andre was amazing it's cool that
she watched I I have another question I
just I want to stay on this historic day
Magnus because
um
like this this was incredible and and we
were we were going nuts and you know you
said in the interview you had with Lex
Friedman on his podcast a couple months
ago that
to paraphrase something you said
yourself something about even if you're
maybe not playing at your Peak that you
once were as a player that you found
that over time you've been you've become
more consistent uh maybe maybe you make
less mistakes and you have you know some
awareness of of some things that you
didn't as a younger player even if you
aren't at your Peak anymore today you
didn't lose a single chess game and
Donnie and I marveled at several moments
where you could have maybe pushed a
little too hard but you didn't you made
a transition into a safer spot what can
you say about that what's come with your
experience over time and the statistical
improbability I made I made a point to
say I don't know that anybody is ever
going to do what you did today again so
what are your thoughts on what you were
able to accomplish today without losing
a game and your experience that's kind
of helped you get here
that's the thing though I mean I don't
uh I don't remember what I I told Lex
but General Adams uh I agree that I'm
more consistent that I used I feel like
my lows are a little bit lower right now
than than they they used to be I I think
in terms of going undefeated uh at some
point it definitely became a goal and as
you said in some games I chose I chose
the safe path
um knowing that I could do something
that I didn't know that it hadn't been
done before but
um it's certainly hadn't been done
against somebody as strong as uh as
Bobby so yeah at some point it was
it was basically all that I was all that
I was playing for first uh towards the
end of the blitz I thought
um it would be really cool not to lose
any games and then
um when the bullet started
um I kind of thought that you know I'm
probably gonna get the random
last year or there but towards the end I
was checking the clock just
and
um
I think when you have these long matches
especially when they're decided pretty
early you got to set yourself goals to
make them more interesting and I
understand that for father this was
Agony but uh for me this was motivation
to try and keep my level up and just
it's it's easy for both to to let go of
the roads like you have seen in a lot of
matches that the level drops drastically
and the level did drop a little bit but
I still felt that I kept it up better
than uh than I usually do
mm-hmm Magnus final question for me are
you going to watch the Argentina Croatia
highlights or did you record the game
no uh I I'm not
I'm not that into it to be honest like I
I'll work I'll watch the games
um if uh if it sort of fits my my
schedule like I've enjoyed it but I I
don't uh like amend my schedule so to to
watch it so I'll certainly I'll
certainly watch some highlights but um
I'm I'm completely fine with uh
uh not watching uh watching it on on
demand
um but just in case there are people
here in
in the chat or watching this video who
have watched chess uh instead of
football and have recorded the game I
will obviously not um
spoil anything
yeah there's uh still 12 000 of them
with us many shows to watch this instead
of the game or maybe they had both on
but uh Magnus you you did you did keep
yourself motivated throughout and you
and you put on a show for the fans that
uh it will that will for
ever be remembered and and thank you for
doing that
um we will we will obviously see you
coming up so my last question before we
bring it out is mvl or so uh the last
time you played in SCC I know you have
the memory versus Maxime in your mind do
you want another chance at uh at Maxime
or who who are you looking forward to
playing
yeah sure I mean beating Maxim wouldn't
be wouldn't be a Revenge but it would be
a step towards for them that's a very
nice so that's what they're hoping to to
play him but honestly I think the match
is uh
uh the match is is a tossed up I think
West has played poorly recently in in
speeches but uh he showed during the um
uh the global test Championship what you
can what he can do so uh he definitely
has the the ability to uh
to win even by a big big margin if he's
uh if he's at his very best so it's
going to be interesting to see
um whether he can ReDiscover this form
because he really needs it for this one
yeah
all right well we wish you the best of
luck in that match regardless of who it
is fans it'll be uh later later this
week when that's happening of course
stay tuned we'll let you know but Magnus
again thank you thank you for uh for the
the show today thank you for the
interview and hope you hope you enjoy
the rest before we see you in your in
your next semi-final matchup
yeah and thank you all so very much for
running this interview pass the start of
title Tuesday so I'm not
a favor I guess we kept you a little
longer so see you man
all right thanks Magnus
all right well there you have it
everyone that was the score I didn't
realize we were keeping him past title
Tuesday that's pretty funny that was
accidental it was it was
but you know it wasn't accidental 22 4.
go ahead totally accidentally he won he
won a couple games Danny stopped making
a big deal out of it he won a couple
games that's all he did no but I mean
seriously he he said he said
what we thought
Donya he he said he set himself a new
goal obviously the match was getting
away from Bobby Hew he was aware of that
but just the mindset a lot of people be
like all right I've won the match I'm
gonna I'm gonna mess around and play
some crazy openings or I'm gonna take my
foot off the gas his mindset was not was
not that it was how do I set a new goal
for myself so that I can almost trick
myself into continuing to perform at
this insanely high level Donya and
honestly I want to hearken back to his
interview after the go cash match I
think some people were thinking yeah
he's kind of putting on a show hey you
won by 15 points no no no it's not fake
it's not disingenuous it's not fake
modesty Magnus really does expect
Perfection from himself and perhaps for
the first time in his SCC career papi in
his chest career he has just put
together three hours of absolute
perfection and this ladies and gentlemen
is what it takes for Magnus Carlson to
be happy with himself and happy with
himself he deserves to be
indeed because again if you're just
tuning in that 22-4 score came in
perfect fashion Magnus Carlson moves on
to the semi-finals where he awaits the
winner of course of Wesley so and Maxine
Bossier the grav uh he did it again
without losing a single game today I
can't believe I'm continuing to say that
how and how amazing what what this was
um that next match of course between
Wesley so and Maxine Basha the grav uh
you will have the call Donya tomorrow
along with Robert Hess your your quick
thoughts now on what we're going to see
manana
we're going to see another amazing match
mvl he has been on form his first match
turned a lot of heads let's not forget
that he crushed none other than an on
form Yanda palmnushy yeah of course
Wesley so has been machine mode for the
last year or so just remember the cgc I
mean talk about Magnus Carlson's
performance today talk about perfection
Wesley so has been darn close to
Perfection uh for for a couple of months
now so I'm super honored to have the
call tomorrow and you know you you
really don't want to miss the match and
if especially since you're going to be
in withdrawal mode after uh the Magnus
match so you won't have to wait long for
more action folks yeah
wow I just still can't I almost don't
want the show to end of what we saw
today that was it was so incredible such
a great interview for Magnus too but
everyone don't worry you have more SCC
tomorrow and if you have been worried
about what to get someone this holiday
season guess what look no further if you
have a chess player in your life they
probably love a premium membership to
chess.com do your holiday party shopping
now get it right now bring a present
that is the chess present of the Year
this holiday season share the beauty of
chess with your loved ones come on
purchase a premium membership that's
right I'm Shilling hard but let's be
real it's actually not that bad of an
idea get a premium membership for your
friend you can give it to him this today
tonight next week this month and uh
don't be a last minute gift Giver take
care of it right now use the command
gift in chat for all the details and uh
and get the job done get the holiday
shopping done all right
Donya that's a shield heart there but
you know what it's important because
it's the gift that keeps on giving makes
you a better chess player you can't be a
better chess player than Magnus Carlson
was today and I just like can I drop an
explicitor before we what the what did
we just watch that was what the first
amazing
we watched like I said I'm gonna keep
repeating it because of how much this is
not an exaggeration one of the greatest
match performances of all time one of
the greatest three hours of Blitz chess
ever played whatever superlative however
you want to phrase it you're not going
to be exaggerating it and I just wanted
to say Danny it was an honor to be a
part of this to call the match and one
sympathizes tremendously with Fabiano
caruana who is in pain for whom this was
not an easy experience but at the end of
the day we watch chess for these
performances this is why we take time
out of our busy days and this is why we
we sit around a table with our cup of
tea and watch matches like this this is
a performance that I am never going to
forget as long as I'm in the Chess World
as long as I'm alive
well said no one who watched it will
forget and no one who watched it will be
sitting out tomorrow they're going to be
here so for everyone who's worked super
hard our team our production staff
everyone who brings these shows to life
our players and of course my amazing
co-host Dania noradinsky International
Master Danny wrench signing off for
today's SCC match and telling you that
we will see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]